[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys it's wednesday here we are
here we are here we are who else would
be here
i got all kinds of presents today oh my
goodness yes indeed you guys yeah patron
and friend of the show ilsa yeah auntie
ilsa that's i know that's what i've been
called the big caller
she sent us to it's like two boxes came
from
uh chewie we got one yesterday and i was
like
i was like wait what is this because i i
have like a thing where every six weeks
like chewie sends me
uh you know a thing of treats and like
some of those mint toys that they love
so much and so i thought it was that for
a second that i opened it it was this
little bag of all of these really cool
like halloween toys all of which are
scattered all over the floor back there
because what happened was i was gonna
leave them in the bag
to show on the show because they're
super cool there's like little mouses
and little crinkle balls but they're all
like halloween
themed so they're all like orange or
like black and white striped and they're
really cool looking and i was like oh
that looks really neat and i'm going to
show that on the show but then as soon
as i opened the box like pookie started
jumping on the back was like open open
open so i had to open it and then she
was like okay now play with them so i
had to like throw them all over the
floor so now they're like all over the
floor back here like all over the floor
dracula's some cats with catnip yeah and
then today yeah we got that box that had
little dracula and cats and oh my god
she again she just jumped right out of
the bag and said please open those yeah
she might i guess you can smell catnip
coming out i'm pretty sure we're just
like cats she knows what cat toys are
yeah she's like oh my god these are for
me
and also you guys
we got these two these are like the
halloween special like ilsa sent us
that's like elsa's so awesome okay so
send us this flavor this is the
temptations like i said the kitty crack
creepy catnip flavor blissful catnip
which you know very awesome very awesome
and look you guys i'm so excited about
this
look
it's the tasty human flavor yeah
i swear to god i heard about this and i
thought i was like why did somebody make
that in photoshop because that's pretty
good like i didn't think it was real i
was like wow that's really funny but no
it's actually real i'm like good on you
temptations that just so funny good
thing about temptations is i was worried
that those things were really high in
calories maybe not too nutritious
because she eats those basically yeah i
mean she'll eat wet food every now and
then but mostly she's just like treats
please and she just eats those like by
the [ __ ]
what we consider real catholic but on
the back it says no this is
high quality cat food it's not real high
in calorie you can feed them whole bowls
of that
so yeah actually kind of half cup so i
must have not have been the only one who
was worried that that's all basically
that's all she wants to eat yeah i mean
every now like i said every now and then
she'll beg and be like hey can i have a
little bit out of the can but then
she'll just like lick the gravy and then
wander off but i wanted to read the back
of this because it's uh this is super
funny one of the things that it says
just in case anyone was curious uh it
says these treats are chicken liver and
beef flavored and do not contain any
humans so you know in case you were
worried that somebody had ground up some
babies and put in there but i kind of i
thought this was funny on the back it
says
uh it says happy halloween it's been
proven that even a little house cat like
me shares dna with lions and tigers if i
were bigger and got a chance i just
might try to eat you i'm sure pookie
probably would thankfully this spooky
season we have temptations mix-ups tasty
human treats to satisfy my craving you
already know i love chicken flavor
chicken liver and beef hand over the
treats so i don't add you to the list
that sounds like like a thread like the
cat's threatening give me those treats
or i'm gonna eat you yeah you're a human
ass yeah i'm sure like yeah probably if
if pookie was big or if we were really
small she would probably eat us without
thinking about it you don't think so no
because um there's a
russian guy who's got a channel and he's
got a mountain lion that's the size of a
person and that thing just [ __ ] loves
him and if you see the behavior it's
just the behavior of a normal house cat
and there are people that have owned
lions you know going back thousands of
years had ancient romans that owned
lions that just walked around inside the
house and they partied with them and uh
no i think if they're hand raised they
don't see people as food
you know
if they got hungry you know what i mean
if they were starving to death i still
don't think they'd eat you
no i don't think they would a dog won't
if you're like if you die in the house
though i think yeah i think after a
while you probably will each you because
you're dead
yeah which you know they're like well
let's not waste that
which is fair enough
i wouldn't be mad i mean you know
pookie could eat me if she needed to
now they see you part of they see you as
part of their little pride you know
their little lion packs so that
granthar's hammer said sick freedom roy
might disagree yeah that was different
though
well
those lion acts and and and tiger acts
man they're trying to get animals to do
something that they don't really want to
do you know
and they're playing games of domination
on these things and chasing them around
they may they may not be totally hand
raised either you know those but
eventually an animal can get pissed off
i mean elephants do all the time
you know i lost stuff too if i was an
elephant in a circus yeah you know they
didn't
they're not living a life that an
elephant is supposed to live you know
and eventually they some of them just
[ __ ] lose it and they start killing
people so i don't blame them i don't
blame a damn
elephant
i don't either not without it but then
some elephants just sweet as hell
there's uh there was an indian elephant
um that some [ __ ] had chained up and
he had damn spikes on his wrists and it
would just sit there and cry
for years and beg for food and people
would feed it plastic and it didn't get
enough to eat
and eventually somebody went down there
and rescued it they filmed the rescuing
of that thing
and it was crying as it was walking away
and got up in the truck because it knew
that let's get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
yeah they're the elephants are
intelligent
you know probably yeah similar to maybe
a little bit more than a chimpanzee
yeah they're way more intelligent than
uh they're giving people yeah
so it you know and that elephant knew
that it was in a bad jam and
it was asking people to help it
you know and you have tears rolling down
its eyes and [ __ ] it wasn't fake you
could see it
you know they were out there with them
cameras in the middle of the night
trying to when they went there and they
started to cut the damn shackles off the
thing they were going to st they stole
the elephant basically
well i probably would have done the same
thing they're not going to lie yeah
well the local authorities were like
didn't didn't agree with it either they
couldn't really give permission to steal
it and they didn't have the right to
take to take it from the guy under
indian laws but then basically the cops
let it be known that there wouldn't be
any investigation if it disappeared yeah
yeah and so
they stole the thing you can see that
story on youtube and then they took it
to an elephant sanctuary it's hanging
out the elephants gained a bunch of
weight and you know that elephant loves
people
so no you there are animals out there
that are far stronger that you can abuse
and they won't lash out to the to the
general public you know
and they won't even lash out against the
abuser
which even they're probably they should
how awesome would that have been if that
elephant would have just like stepped on
yeah crush that dude
and everybody'd be like oh well
he had that coming he was kind of just
an [ __ ]
grifter dude who really
tried to make money off of [ __ ]
getting an elephant to beg for him and
sell drugs on the side and this guy was
just you know living in a [ __ ]
mud hut basically you know somewhere in
one of those indian outskirts indian
towns and
people said give that over that elephant
you can't afford to feed it and he's
like nope you know well i kind of feel
like if you own an animal
that and you don't like you mistreat it
i kind of feel like one it has every
right to eat you and two people have
every right to like take it from you it
had shackles on its legs and it had
screws on the inside of the shackles an
inch long and it was sitting there it
was just rubbing them right down
that's how he kept it [ __ ]
that's how he kept it um docile let's
just keep it in constant pain it
couldn't walk just horrible
i'd have [ __ ] done something to that
dude he's lucky
yeah i mean i'm down something that dude
like i said i don't i don't you know i'm
not a big fan of like people do [ __ ]
people either but i mean anybody that
would do that to an animal that's the
same kind of person yeah really i mean
you don't give a [ __ ] about anything
other than yourself clearly no i've made
sure that his life would have changed
forever let's just say it that way and
like i said in some ways like like
treating an animal like that is like
treating a child
yeah and nobody puts up with that crap
no so no you know i've never been the
same when i was done with him yeah
you guys can just
read from that what you will
i'm in a dude way to buckle five you
know to be like fighting a child but he
would there would
he would uh not be the same afterwards
yeah yeah i mean you know if the
elephant could consent it would be cool
if he could just like stick that dude up
the elephant's butt but you know that
don't don't do that to the elephant
either yeah
don't get him involved in it although i
would have been happy if like the
elephant had stepped on the [ __ ]
you know
he would have got some mafia justice it
would have been something like that
something you'd saw on [ __ ] you know
something you'd see behind the godfather
yeah gram there's hammer also points out
treating bears like homies didn't work
out so well for grizzly man either
that's true
although it was just the one bear and
he's to be fair and to be fair he
predicted that that was the bear that
would eat him
yeah so he did seem to be i mean he hung
out with lots of bears and it was just
that but i guess it only takes one
really but yeah and that particular bear
was an old weak bear that wasn't eating
properly and was would settle for a
shitty meal and a man is a shitty meal
from a point of view of a [ __ ]
bear
although they'll eat out of garbage cans
so i mean there's not much meat there
yeah that's true you know we're kind of
stringy
[Laughter]
there's video of them
bear
defeating and getting ready to eat a
bore a wild boar that [ __ ] pig was
screaming and it was just had it by the
neck and was just trying to wear it out
that boar tried to get away and
everybody was coming out of their cars
filming it it was happening on the side
of the road
and eventually that bear drug that bore
up the damn
incline
side of the hill and disappeared with it
they will they will they're not really
predators the bears are not apex
predators they're more like a an
opportunist or a scavenger
they're collecting berries and they'll
find [ __ ] and they'll eat carry and if
it's fresh
and
they're they'll get fish and [ __ ] you
know but they're not really hunters
they're not they they will hunt but it's
just that's just like a side just like
we don't want to work if we don't have
to hunting is hunting big animals it's
dangerous and you can get hurt if they
get hurt they can't they can't get first
aid yeah so it's safer to get fish
yeah granters also says uh don't kid
yourself if pookie were the size of a
mountain lion you'd be breakfast if she
woke up hungry i disagree
i don't know i i'm i don't know if she'd
eat me or not she might she might eat me
no if they're hand-raised they're
totally different there are people that
have hand-raised them and had them in
houses for [ __ ] thousands of years
although to be honest i'm not real sure
i think that pookie thinks that she's a
person she thinks they think they're
humans yeah i mean she thinks that she's
the same species as we are yeah i think
yeah um you know i you know i don't know
obviously i don't know what's going on
in her little mind but she seems to
think that she's a little person the
main difference between the
all those cats is just the size
the bigger they are the more of uh the
more dominant they think they are
but like i said if your hand raised a
cat from an early age they they won't
turn on you unless you deserve to be
turned on if you're abusing the cathy
yeah which like i said i don't have a
problem with that at all but um
no i mean they got a russian guy who
[ __ ] owns a mountain lion that's
[ __ ] big man and
it's a male 1 well it's bigger than he
is yeah it's a male mountain lion and it
waits for him when he's coming home from
work and [ __ ] it acts just like a
little bitty that's just like a cat and
uh
his mama is a [ __ ] you know like a 22
year old pretty russian girl and she
just talks about him missy messi
m-e-s-s-i messi
i am puma you can it's on youtube
and he gets up in the bed with him and
[ __ ]
curls up with him and [ __ ] licks him
on the side of the face and
that [ __ ] mountain lion loves that
man it just does
when you see it
you know love when you see it
he takes it outside and walks it around
on a leash and he's got pajamas for it
that yeah because he takes it out into
the snow yeah
and you know you have he has to have a
collar on it
make sure nobody shoots it you know
because they have guns in russia yeah
and um
it's just a
it's a it's like a giant house cat
exactly like a giant house cat but he's
got habitat for it and feeds it he's got
money
and uh no that that's that cat is
definitely a part of the family
runs around inside the house and
you know
he trusts it more than you would
to me it looked more trustworthy than a
dog
than a big dog
i mean so affectionate and the thing
about it too is that you i mean just
like people um it's gonna come down to
the individual animal i don't i mean not
necessarily i don't think any animal
would necessarily eat you
if the circumstances were correct but
some of them absolutely would because
it's just like anything else like some
people have cats or dogs or you know
other pets that are kind of [ __ ]
yeah and that's just kind of what
they're like that's their personality
type just like humans um so you know
maybe they'd be more likely to lash out
but then on the other hand maybe there
would be some that wouldn't do that he
knows what he's doing though too he's
got habitats he lets it socialize with
other big cats
he's got
he's got a couple of other cats at the
house a different type somebody look at
someone look like servals or and big
lakes type cats he's got those
they all just have fun
there but it looks like a parts of the
house look like a zoo kind of you know
what i mean habitats and [ __ ] they'll
get a big um
inflatable swimming pool and fill it
full of water and give him sturgeon and
he'll jump in there and try to catch
sturgeon and
ends up [ __ ] the pool up
because it's you know the claws will
tear them down by so many yeah he knows
yeah there goes that pool and the
[ __ ] water goes everywhere that's
okay every month you know every month he
gets a [ __ ] pool and a [ __ ] some
sturgeon
so i'm sure that cat's like whoa it's
like my birthday yeah
well again the first time you gave the
sturgeon in the swimming pool and
[ __ ] the water got everywhere jumping
in the pool trying to [ __ ] catch the
sturgeon that's like a four foot long
sturgeon
in his mouth and [ __ ]
that's what he can do now he's like just
hit a hole oh no i caught it yeah yeah
you know i'm proud of myself
so
it all depends on your relationship with
that animal
it's the same with horses
some people think horses are safe in
general they are i've run across horses
that are dangerous as [ __ ] that's what i
mean some of them are [ __ ] just like
people but there's usually a stud you
know somebody that hasn't been gelded
and they're
got a lot of testosterone and he's alpha
male and he's not listening to no
[ __ ] human yes you're just gonna cut
their nuts off and then everything will
be fine
but now they have to be because that's
their job is to breed yeah you know so
you got to be real careful with
some of those studs they're just [ __ ]
mean you know they don't listen to
people that's not the idea that's not
they're like i'm bigger than you like
[ __ ] you yeah i'm just gonna kick you
yeah
and um tell me what to do there are
dudes that up there in canada
and alaska that own [ __ ]
giant [ __ ] grizzly bears and [ __ ]
kodiaks and
those bears [ __ ] love that dude
you see that on video
dude just keeps preparing you're a good
bear you're just looking wrestling
like a big clown
but you have to [ __ ] but the thing is
not anybody could do that it's that
particular man and that and that
particular baby regular bear is there
like i said most of the time probably
that bear would just eat your face if
that bear didn't know you you'd be
you'd be risking something probably
you know if that man was with you then
maybe it'd be safer but
i just think was [ __ ] huge yeah i
still wouldn't really trust yeah because
it's like you know i might smell like a
snack so i don't really know
i might just decide that he doesn't
really like you
yeah it's like i don't care if my friend
is here or not i'm just gonna eat that
[ __ ]
she smells delicious yeah uh yeah so
danny rolling ghost faces birds of prey
eat outside cats left and right
[ __ ] having your kidding outdoor cat hon
honestly when pookie was small we did
actually worry about that although when
she went out on the back porch we always
had somebody like one of us was watching
her yeah so she wouldn't like wander off
and sometimes we always like kept an eye
on her with flashlight and stuff but so
we got eagles here yeah because bald
eagles um so
but now she's bigger i don't worry about
as much but honestly since we've moved
to this house she doesn't really seem
interested in going outside anymore she
saw that dog one time
yeah
next door they have two dogs and like i
said they you know they run around
outside in the backyard they look like
they're inside most of the time but
sometimes they're out in the backyard
and they're behind a fence and stuff but
they're very boisterous
and um you know so i guess pookie like
heard them and she was just like yeah
[ __ ] going outside so she'll sit up on
this on the windows like on the second
floor like on the windowsill and look
out but she doesn't really she doesn't
scratch she doesn't try to get out or
try to go out the front or anything like
that i think beijing tried to go out one
time and she'll go out and sit on the
back porch but pookie doesn't really
seem to care
she's like kind of weirded out i guess
by the new area and she doesn't like
because i mean this house it's not like
the the old house where we had
you know all the trees and bushes and
stuff like that and then there were
other houses with trees and bushes like
really close by so there was a lot of
places for her to hide
this one i mean this place we have a
couple bushes around the outside but
it's really really open like it's this
big huge open yard and maybe that freaks
her out yeah you know that's kind of
what i was thinking because there's not
really a lot of places for her to hide
outside
it looks like we got a
good enough crowd now looks like people
showed up let me go ahead and just talk
what are we talking about tonight
we're doing kind of like a little bit of
a pre-halloween special i guess we're
going to do like some kind of paranormal
or some weird kind of [ __ ] like that
we're doing the so-called mercy brown
vampire incident
otherwise known as the last vampire in
new england i don't know that one case
and we're also talking about bridget
cleary
uh sometimes known as the fairy murder
or the cleary changeling
something like that it was like a
murdered case that took place in ireland
like back in the late 19th century
um you know and there's like a
not a not a paranormal
aspect to it necessarily but there was
some paranormal belief involved
in how the murder took place yeah some
hold on one of my little gun
fans in there said that uh i want to
point out that the strange thing about
russian
laws is that they don't allow rifled
barrels yeah i remember back in the day
if i could knew some dudes that worked
to the ishmash company in the early
internet back in the 90s
uh the dude that was talking about
helped run it smash and uh which is
russian
one of the russian arsenals he ended up
dying though his name he went by the
name tantal and [ __ ] he would sell
all kinds of cool [ __ ]
legally you know just like rare magazine
bodies and [ __ ] a bison magazine i
remember i don't know if you remember
the old [ __ ] nine millimeter mac
bison it was like an ak short brother jk
with a tubular magazine and nine
millimeter makarov that went underneath
there he was selling those and those
things were [ __ ] super rare and guys
were assembling bisons here
basically by hand in the 90s
semi-auto versions anyway
what was weird is that it was also the
board with the civilian zones there were
aks like in in in [ __ ] 410 shotgun
and weird [ __ ] like that or
weird versions of like smoothbore aks
but the bullets were rifled they had all
their ways to get around it anyway last
i heard from uh
russian guys is that uh they were
changing those laws they were gonna
allow rifles to be owned that they're
going through like a slow process of
allowing
um
russian civilians to uh
have rifled barrels
so i think
and they're gonna they were gonna kind
of introduce it slowly evidently
but um
yeah they're they're getting rid of some
of those weird russian laws
it wasn't normal for russia to have
strict gun control
pre-bolshevik revolution it was like
america everybody had them
they made them they gave them all up and
[ __ ] those dudes ended up in camps
don't give your [ __ ] up ever
okay go ahead that's all i'm gonna say
victor said chickens eat mice so if a
chicken got big enough it would probably
eat a cat
like a giant i just had a weird that's a
terrible like [ __ ] mental image a
giant chicken eating a cat
um
yeah and then they're talking about owls
yeah we have owls too
i haven't seen like i hear them a lot
remember we said there was that pair of
them that lived on the path that i used
to walk on and i would hear them calling
back and forth to each other they
weren't super big though but i had i
have seen like some really big owls
around here
not so much but i don't know yeah so i
do worry about pokey i would honestly
i'm glad that since we moved to this
house she doesn't really seem to want to
go out anymore she's having too much fun
in here i mean i can't say outside
because she knows that word
so
so if she hears that she might like
think of it so i always have to spell it
until she figures out elsa just showed
up we just talked about you also
yeah we were showing all the toys that
you sent to pookie oh my god yeah she
loved that [ __ ] pookie is so into
the toys and the temptations i had to
like all the all the little halloween
like all the little orange mice and
stuff like that um i had to like take
them all out of the bag they're all
scattered all over the back of the floor
over there because i was gonna leave in
the bag so i could like show them on the
show but
pookie was like insistent she's like
open this bag like right now she kept
like scratching and scratching and
scratching when i was trying to like
record some [ __ ] and i was kind of like
okay fine so i dumped all the stuff out
and then she was like flinging
everything around and playing with all
the crinkly balls she's having a [ __ ]
great time i mentioned it earlier in the
show
uh the back of that temptation box kind
of settled my uh worries because man
that's almost all she eats i thought
those things might have been like really
high calorie like oreos or something
it says they're just they're just like
any other cat food they can eat whole
bowls of them they're not even that high
in calorie really they're two calories
per treat yeah
which
they give you you know they can live off
of them it's just a high quality
high quality
cat food
i thought it was like crack that's what
i mean like i thought it was like the
cat equivalent of oreos and i felt
really bad because i was like why would
you eat your regular food right it's
like she you know you put out like some
wet food that we have like you know the
fancy feast or whatever and she'll like
kind of lick it and she's like meh
and then she wanders off but then she's
treats she'll eat [ __ ] bowls full of
that [ __ ] we've had people give us all
different kinds of treats she'll eat
other treats but nah not for lunch oh
the other thing is she's really patient
she likes temptations and she really
likes those sheba meat sticks sheba meat
sticks
like they come like two or three like in
a packet yeah and she loves those it's
like beef jerky in the background yeah
they're like that long she likes those
she'll eat like half and then leave half
and then she'll come back and eat the
other half we got sent uh like fish
fillets so like fresh fish she won't
touch them
she kind of likes those little dried
fishies she likes to drive fishies a
little bit but she'll get sick of those
she'll eat one maybe every few days if
you give her too many of them she goes
no
but the meat sticks she actually asks
for those she'll like says we keep him
in the drawer by the bed and she'll kind
of be like hey can i have some of those
so when you pull it out she'll be like
oh she hears a crinkle of the meat stick
packets sheba meat sticks for those
you're just she it's funny she doesn't
like real food she likes process type
stuff like when i put that fish fillet
out i was like oh she's gonna like this
and she went over there and smelled it
and went oh no
that's not food well i'm trying to even
like give her tuna out of a can and
stuff and she's just like not super she
gets excited about it like it's like it
smells good because like i'll open
something to make a sandwich or
something and she'd be like oh what's
that
going on and then she goes nut and she's
like not for pokey yeah weird she's
super weird i don't know why
well and remember how like beijing was
she'll eat tuna beijing is really into
parmesan cheese
she really likes that that just cheated
that kraft parmesan cheese yeah you pile
it up in a little pile there and just
lick it all up
she loves that [ __ ] i don't know it's so
weird i think there's cheese in those
temptations too yeah also saying those
tasty human ones are so funny see like i
first saw that and i thought they were
fake and i'm like oh my god that's so
funny i wish those were real and they
are real so i'm like really really
excited
they're and i love how on the back it
says a disclaimer it's like there's not
actually any human in it so like don't
be alarmed
[Music]
zack's wondering what the biggest spider
in the world is
i thought it was uh a goliath spider but
i could be wrong besides the dinner
plate yeah they're very very big
although like i said the
sometimes they say oh as big as a dinner
plate which sounds impressive until
they're like well they're talking about
their leg span as well as their body i'm
like if you saw one whose body was as
big as a dinner plate then that would be
a whole different kettle of fish but
never seen they were thinking of this
countless but camel spiders aren't that
big yeah i didn't think camel spiders
that big i thought a goliath spider was
about
i've seen pictures of the goliath spider
in like somebody's hand and they're way
bigger than like somebody's hand what
they're talking about is there's a
famous photograph of some guys from the
first first or second gulf war i called
the second girl go florida where a guy
has a [ __ ]
camel spider on the end of a rod and
he's holding it at a certain angle
dead on to the camera it's forced
perspective it looks like bigger it
looks like it's the size of a huge
[ __ ] crab
or a [ __ ]
alaskan king crab like it's two feet
long you know this legs it's not it's
about four inches long three inches long
and from there on out people thought
that these crab spiders are huge they're
not
it's just the perspective of that
[ __ ]
forced perspective of that [ __ ] shot
famous photo
they're not very big they're not they're
not even very
dangerous they'll bite but not that bad
you usually wake up marco says camel
spiders aren't even spiders i think yeah
they might be scorpions
yeah i thought it was scorpion with it
without a tail
and victor says in that pick there's two
of them holding two of them all together
yeah
makes it look even bigger yeah i'm
pretty sure like i said i could be wrong
it's been a while since i i used to have
all these safari cards and [ __ ] like
that so i was like a real dork about all
the animals and stuff i back in the day
the goliath spider was the largest
spider but i don't know if they found a
bigger one since then and they are about
i can't remember offhand like how big
they are but they're really
i mean if you saw one you would like
[ __ ] your pants probably like if you saw
in your bathtub or something
and what would really scare me is be
down there [ __ ] dive and deep sea
diving
and turn around and see one of those
damn alaskan king crabs [ __ ] like 12
foot [ __ ] arm span you know [ __ ] that
that's like a huge [ __ ] underwater
spider there it time they don't they
don't scare me i guess maybe because
they're so delicious yeah if i saw it
i'd be like
i'm gonna eat you
it's just funny you know when you see
them all assembled and you see them
[ __ ] when you see them
yeah they're like that's a [ __ ]
spider
when you see the ball itself it's a
water spot like a lego yeah yeah uh yeah
grandpa's hammer said i saw fruit bats
when i went to south africa they were
like flying cats yeah free bats are
really big i saw some at
animal kingdom or busch gardens or
something like that they have like this
huge enclosure that has all these uh
fruit bats so like flying foxes and
stuff like that
yeah those [ __ ] like really really big i
thought they were super adorable though
yeah they make great pets they have like
cute little faces yeah and i was like oh
i kind of want one people have owned own
them and they'll keep them in a
refrigerator hanging upside down put the
refrigerator on low because they like it
cool and dark
they'll let them out just like me yeah
and they're real cuddly and affectionate
and [ __ ] just like
like a
not even like a mouse more like a cat or
something yeah like i said it's like a
kitty except yeah with wings yeah how
cool is that
yeah and if they'll just sit there like
a baby and petting them and you know the
women are oh you're so cute it's like
curled up going yeah yeah i don't know
holy crap
pookie would probably love that if we
got like another little thing that fruit
it's like oh it's like a kitty but it
can fly
it's got a face that looks like a dog or
a fox you know it's called flying fox
and you feeding them they're feeding
them and [ __ ] and they're looking at
you big old eyes like oh thank you
they're [ __ ] adorable i just thought
bats were super cute yeah i know that's
[ __ ] ugly but they're not they're
well they're ugly in a way that's that's
cute though you know what i mean there's
there's there's kind of like an ugly
that's also kind of cute with their
little upturned noses and stuff yeah you
know i ain't remember
flying fox is like not even
dealing with a bat we're like dealing
with a dog yeah like i said it looks
like a little dog or cat but they can
fly holy crap can you imagine a pookie
could fly how much trouble she get into
yeah she gets into enough trouble as it
is with just her little feet holy crap
she's i think because of the stuff that
elsa sent her with that probably all of
it had catnip in it so she got like
super hepped up on the catnip so she has
been like running all over this house
like because i kept doing the bonanza
theme at her because it sounds like a
little horse like a herd of horses
coming at me like
coming down the hall running and jumping
over all the boxes and stuff going
where's all the toys where's all the
toys she's like been doing that all day
she's freaking crazy yeah some of those
king crabs are like 12 feet across if
you were standing next to it you'd
rather prove it
was
so much delicious meat yeah i'm coming
at him with like a big with a stick of
butter
[Laughter]
no
the body with bigger you know as big as
a flattened out basketball you know
big old [ __ ] legs and [ __ ]
[ __ ] up elsa said yeah i wanted to
drug pookie up ha ha i know she's gonna
be up all night now probably like climb
it all over us and everything yeah
i think last night when we got home
because we went to rifftrax live last
night so we didn't get home until kind
of late
and i was like really sleepy and i'm
going to sleep and all of a sudden i
feel pooky's little legs
she like climbs up my body and then
she's
sitting there like on my shoulder
because i was laying on my side and i
hear tom go
pookie don't stand on your mommy
just scanning
like i said standing there i claimed it
i claimed this person
yeah that's [ __ ] ridiculous
she doesn't like when i lay on my side
if i'm laying on my side
she'll like kind of climb up and she
stands on my shoulder and just kind of
stands there she's like she likes it if
i lay on my back so she can lay on my
chest and make this i saw the whole
thing [ __ ] happen
[Laughter]
she got on the [ __ ] foot of the bed
and walked up and climbed up on top and
walked right up to her shoulder and just
stood there and just stood there looking
down at her yep
i was like what are you doing don't
stand on your mom
she will though that's why because she's
like turn over on your back mommy she's
like i want to lay on your chest and
make jesus
uh somebody asked what was the rifftrax
movie oh it was good
amityville the evil escapes
amityville 4. amityville 4. oh man that
movie
it was a good one man that was oh that
that was like one of the funniest ones
we were brought to well it start old
people old women
can we we need to talk about this for a
second because
it starts spock's mom spock's mom was in
it yeah uh patty duke
50-something-year-old patty dude yeah
and
some really strange children in some
really really tragic 80s fashions oh man
that [ __ ] 80s fashion [ __ ] tour i
could remember man
[ __ ] look hey
crappers i was you took me right back to
1986 87 like [ __ ] trenton high school
with the [ __ ] french jackets and
those [ __ ] boots with the [ __ ]
fringe everything was like super puffy
puffy [ __ ] shoulder pads uh big puffy
tennis shoes old women with [ __ ]
headbands rough rolled up headbands big
huge chunky statement jewelry that's
like this big just like [ __ ] badge
and the golden girls
that decor the houses which is [ __ ]
trinkets everywhere jam-packed little
[ __ ] tables with [ __ ] everything
on them and boomer bling just [ __ ]
boomer bling all over the [ __ ] house
and and then they had like the teenage
girl who couldn't walk just as [ __ ]
crazy as walk yeah walking the deal with
shoulders way back to try to get her
boobs as high up as she could and she
was like a second rate kind of [ __ ]
um
the girl from [ __ ] terminator what
was that caller linda linda linda
hamilton she's kind of like a
like a second-rate lip but with a really
weird i don't know like her jawline was
very strange she had a big jaw with a
little bitty chin i didn't know if that
i mean it didn't look natural i guess it
could be
she she just had a real [ __ ] square
jaw but she was very lean and she had a
very protruding chin like she had like
this really big square jaw and like this
little bitty tiny like kind of it was so
weird looking it was i think it was bad
it was just weird looking linda hamilton
had had a face like that just not quite
as extreme she had an extreme version
it was like you
i want to say you took linda hamilton
and put her in a f in a fun
house went to hamilton and you maybe
like face tuned her in a funny way it's
what you kind of look yeah it looked a
little unnatural yeah and maybe it was
natural i don't know it was only about
16-17 maybe but it didn't look like it
looked like a really strange like
surgical choice yeah it did but it
wasn't it wasn't it was just she was
really young and lean
uh oh and he knew amityville four that
was the lamp one right so this is what
located so before i hadn't seen
amityville four i saw obviously i saw
the first one and i saw a couple of the
other ones but i'd never seen this one
so when i saw that the subtitle was the
evil escapes
when we were on the way to the theater
i told tom i said i bet you that this is
one of those things that you see in a
lot of kind of like b and c list horror
franchises
where
they just buy some cheap ass script that
didn't have anything to do with the
franchise and then like tweak it to have
something to do with the franchise so
it's like it doesn't have anything dude
there's no continuity or anything yeah
she called it man right from the title i
said well if it was me and somebody like
you know and i had to do that it's like
yeah we'll call it the evil escapes that
way we don't have to film it in the
actual andyville house or have anything
to do with the original story she called
it that's what happened yeah so well you
know i'm well versed in this in this
horror kind of [ __ ] and like i said
these kind of like cheap ass franchise
not like your a-list franchises okay
like you're you know nightmare on elm
streets or your friday the 13th i'm
talking about like your you know
children of the corn yeah um you know
puppet master like you know the kind of
like c and d list kind of uh franchises
which some of which are still good but
they have like 40 bajillion sequels and
i don't even know how many amityville
movies there are a [ __ ] ton too many so
yeah so the whole premise of this one it
was a bunch of old
women
dismiss me everybody's an old woman in
this
um and it bogs the movie down
[Laughter]
it was it was old battle axes the movie
but um you know nothing against old
women i'm awesome yeah so i'm just
saying you can't use well no they were
really old well yeah i'm talking about
league of legends like elderly just
can't make a movie
you can't make a driving movie around a
bunch of women in their 70s it's just
it's just not gonna work yeah and you
know so so the whole premise of this
was that there is this horrifyingly ugly
lamp
that was in the original amityville
house that you never saw except yeah
that you never saw and somebody because
yeah you would definitely remember this
yeah i never saw it yet um because that
layup was something else so the lamp is
in a garage sale somebody buys it and
ships it out to their sister aunt
somebody in california yeah and palace
bird is yeah and the lamp yeah is
possessed by a demon or something so
it's basically haunted lamp the movie
only we tacked on some amityville i
didn't have time to explain to jenny
but some of the establishing shots of
where the house in california is
supposed to be there's we're out in the
middle of nowhere no you're not that's
palace verdes and [ __ ] i know that's
right where my dad used to take me to
watch them watching the people jumping
off the cliff with the hang gliders yeah
all right i almost fell off that cliff a
couple times like as a little kid that
was a trip and i got left there as a
little kid my dad my i got in the back
of the guy he's like [ __ ] that kid yeah
yeah got back to the camper i don't need
this kid anymore someone will pick him
up wait for us to leave and we need to
leave
and i jumped out the back
see where my dad went and all of a
sudden [ __ ] camper took took off oh
my god it was like an urban legend yeah
i got left there i was about [ __ ]
five
so i went running up the hill and that
little hill where they were driving up
to go down there with the parking lot it
was in that parking lot i ran up that
hill and they had the old couple up
there selling fruit and she was in the
old lady was i can remember i was crying
my [ __ ] eyes at like five she goes oh
you got left here then he was like yeah
oh don't worry they'll be back and i
just sit up there with the old lady oh
man he'll be back he'll be back and they
were right [ __ ] my dad came back
where the hell what the hell happened
what if he hadn't come back i really
didn't feel like oh well my mom would
have kicked his ass
yeah
i can start again i have another kid
yeah
i jumped out the back of the camper
well that's your fault it was my fault
yeah that's what i mean that wasn't your
parents no he didn't know he didn't know
that i got it they just said be like oh
well yeah
[Laughter]
but that parking lot and that [ __ ]
road that went up twice i remember that
was from my childhood you just go there
all the time
yeah it's funny yeah that's pretty funny
and that house is not there
well obviously they they do that a lot
like establishing shots but then they
filmed it's the house like some other
[ __ ] place right right off from that
thing is the [ __ ] highway they just
think it wasn't 101 nothing gets further
in but there's a highway right there and
also before they did the movie because
they usually do a short so they can like
have a two-hour presentation
if the movie's not long enough so they
did a short beforehand and they did an
industrial accident short
and that was one of the weirdest [ __ ]
things i've ever seen and i've seen a
lot of like weird industrial accident
shorts
for whatever reason like the dude in
this who
stuck his hand in a machine and got his
fingers cut off but that wasn't even
like the main point of the thing the
main point of the thing was that this
dude was super obsessed
with tomatoes
and they came in a fruit basket and many
times in this short which was only
probably like eight minutes long
um there were many uh kind of instances
of him eating a tomato as though it was
an apple except putting salt on it and
them talking about how much he loved
tomatoes and his daughter made him a
fruit basket which had normal fruit in
it but then also had tomatoes so
i know tomatoes are a fruit okay i know
that but nobody puts them in [ __ ]
fruit baskets so
i'm making some moderators because we
don't have any okay
yeah oh yeah with some of our i thought
some of the people i thought i thought
zach was a moderator yeah yeah he's
making sure we have several yeah okay
okay
what is it if it if it's blue they're a
moderator right that's what i said yeah
okay i'm just making sure we didn't say
that i just said that okay
[Laughter]
yeah he might come yeah some of those
accident shorts are hilarious they're
all like really funny i can't even we
just had like a big long discussion
about it on the way home they did a lot
of those on mst and i was like i always
really like when they dig up a new one
because those [ __ ] things are so
[ __ ] weird sheila anne said my uncle
ate tomatoes like that maybe that was a
thing back then
you know
i never really heard of that like i love
tomatoes as much as the next person but
i never saw anybody eat them
like an apple i mean i've seen people
eat that like slice them and like eat
them with salt or cottage cheese or
something on them but i've never really
seen anything
just pick them up out of a fruit basket
and be like oh
that was something it's a little bit
weird that was some old school [ __ ] that
was like
three grandparents
that was when tomatoes were exotic they
didn't have italian food it wasn't in
the mainstream so they weren't this is
when they still thought they were
poisonous
yeah i think the only thing
tomatoes were considered fruit then i
remember well they are fruit technically
i know but they just weren't making
italian tomato sauces
the closest thing to italian tomato
sauce that they had been eaten would
have been tomato soup cream of tomato
soup yeah they'd have made that
ilsa says cucumbers and salt are great i
agree and honestly
i really love one of my favorite
sandwiches is just a bagel with
cucumbers and a little bit of cream
cheese on like plain cream cheese and a
little and some salt
that shit's delicious
i don't know why it's just really really
refreshing
so uh yeah we've been going almost an
hour already how's that yeah it's time
to go so you want to like talk about
some of these cases everybody's like uh
a lot of people said they hadn't really
heard about these uh these cases i
haven't heard about them either so
i had heard about the mercy brown case
and i think like i said rob said earlier
that he had sent me a picture of her
gravestone
uh which you can still visit in rhode
island by the way
uh so i had been wanting to cover this
for a while i think i put it in the poll
like a bunch of times but it never won
but this time it won because it was
halloween and also i put in like the
whole cleary changeling thing because i
just saw
some old like um one of those creepy
weird history shows on netflix or
something
uh or toby and i saw this case on there
i'm like oh yeah i kind of remember
hearing about that the cleary changeling
and i was like oh yeah maybe i'll throw
that in there too because the mercy
brown vampire cases it's not like super
complicated so i want to do like a
couple kind of creepy things like that
because you know it's halloween week
cucumber tea sandwiches uh yeah big time
those are really really good
yeah so a lot of people are saying that
people back in the day like their
grandparents and stuff used to eat
tomatoes like that yeah huh
that's really odd i'd never seen anybody
eat tomatoes like that like i said i'd
seen people slice them up
and eat them
you know just like on the side well they
were also eating kumquats like that
yeah but i never saw anybody pick one up
out of a fruit basket and just eat it
like that yeah i just thought that was
kind of strange
yeah i didn't like tomatoes when i was a
kid either
i just i just like in the south i
remember meeting like eating them like
that right out of the garden
and uh they did the same thing with
cucumbers
yeah they just hit it with a uh what do
you call it carrot peeler yeah and take
the skin off of it
sprinkle salt on it i can see that and
just start eating it yeah which probably
looks super dirty if you're like
watching it
[Laughter]
along those lines they're just crunchy
eating like it was you know [ __ ] like
almost like almost like a corn on the
cob but just eating the whole thing they
eat corn on the cob like that too of
course
yeah just to get an ear of corn and just
boil it
and then just [ __ ] just take it and
rub it across that hot corn cob just
[ __ ] rub it across the top of [ __ ]
some butter yeah stick of butter well
yeah we did that sprinkle salt and
pepper on it or if i can cajun cajun
seasoning and just go to town on it
yeah we're throwing it in with a crab
boil too in the shrimp boil
we need to do that [ __ ] again yeah yeah
we're talking about we keep talking
about that you can get some steaks
you need to get some shrimp man i
haven't i haven't had a big old steak in
a really long time get some potatoes and
some corn corn on the cob just boil it
all make a damn
shrimp boil
that would be really really good sorry
here's somebody outside yelling let's be
one of our neighbors
yeah tammy says pick the cucumber young
enough you don't even need to peel it
yeah there you go i mean i think you can
technically eat the peels but i think it
kind of like upsets your stuff yeah they
kind of they're kind of tough yeah it's
like hard to digest it's roughage
yeah if you slice them long ways or a
thin waist you know what i mean there's
not much on the outside you can eat that
but if you're just crunching it we're
trying to bite it with your teeth you
know it's kind of tough because
sometimes if you go to like a restaurant
sometimes they have salads where it
looks like they haven't really bothered
peeling the cucumbers they just like cut
them you know like in coins like that
but they still have like the rind on the
outside yeah part of the rhine yeah
which you know it has stripes or
something like i said it probably just
yeah i think it's just like hard to
digest that's all
all right so let's talk about
the mercy brown vampire incident
and honestly
this was kind of like the last one of
these incidents i guess and this is
several hundred years after the whole
salem witch trial debacle
but apparently there was kind of like a
little mini
run on
everybody suddenly thinking that there
were vampires running around for a
little while
in new england like right around the end
of the 19th century which you know in
case you're counting is not really that
long ago people actually still kind of
believed in vampires and it all had to
do
with
tuberculosis
because they didn't really understand
like what caused it or how to cure it or
anything like that so
every you know i guess it was like a lot
of farmers and a lot of kind of rural
people and they were just kind of like
saw some weird [ __ ] going on and they're
just like you know
obviously vampires
that you know which is obviously the
first thing conclusion that you would
jump to sure
so this happened the mercy brown
incident which like i said she's kind of
called the last vampire in new england
there were some before this which i'll
get into in a little bit but this is
like the most famous one
so this happened in the very late uh
1800s in exeter rhode island
so there's this farmer named george
brown
um and he lived on a farm with his
family
and in 1883 uh his wife mary
she uh died of tuberculosis which
obviously then was known as consumption
so that was 1883.
six months after that
his daughter who was named mary olive
she was 20 years old
she also died of consumption
now then he had a son named edwin
and he seemed to be like getting the
same kind of symptoms so he started
getting like thinner and weaker and
paler
uh over like the winter of 1892.
now while he was sick and convalescing
george's other daughter whose name was
mercy brown
she had actually been sick for a year
and she died in january of 1892 at which
point edwin was the only kid that was
like you know well he was an adult but
you know he was the only one of george's
kids that was still left alive so he was
um understandably kind of freaking out
because like you know his three
daughters are dead his wife is dead or
his two daughters are dead his wife is
dead and now his son looks to be going
the same way
so they send edwin away to colorado
springs because back then they thought
oh well if you were sick you had to go
somewhere like dry and hot
like that was gonna fix you
so edwin goes out to colorado springs
for like a year and a half and seemed to
get a little bit better but not really
and he was i guess kind of like homesick
and stuff
uh so he ended up coming back home like
in 1890 i think it was 1892 1890 yeah
1892 like spring of 1892.
so like i said uh you know edwin's
getting sick the dad is kind of like
they know that it's a disease i guess
because like i said they called it
consumption but they didn't know what
caused it they didn't know what cured it
and they didn't understand they didn't
really seem to understand how contagious
it was
because it was very very common around
this time period for whole families to
be wiped out by consumption because like
i said you all live in the same house
you're all breathing the same air and
drinking the same water and [ __ ] like
that so obviously shit's gonna pass
around but having your whole family
wiped out that's kind of alarming
so people are looking for
someone to blame you know something
something they can kind of like
get a handle on i guess because they
don't really understand
yeah that's what i mean because they
don't really understand what's causing
it it's like my whole [ __ ] family is
dead right
now edwin like i said he kind of
lingered for like a year and a half with
it
and he eventually ended up um you know
passing away
so after he died so george is the only
one left his wife is dead and all his uh
you know grown kids are dead at this
point
so even though this wasn't entirely
george's idea at first
but all the other townsfolk in exeter
they started getting the idea
that
well
there's probably a vampire out running
around you have to think that
a lot of the you know the the people
that lived in new england at this time
were you know immigrants or were you
know descended from immigrants like
european immigrants so they had kind of
brought a lot of these sort of
superstitions with them
and one of the main superstitions i kind
of feel like the vampire lore
this is not really something that's big
in vampire lore anymore but back in the
day
one of the big things that in vampire
lore was that
when a vampire came back from the grave
it would go after its own family members
first and like pick them off one by one
you know what i mean so i kind of feel
like that's not real commonly known
anymore
um but that was actually a big part of
vampire lore back in the day that that
that your family was in the biggest
you know was the biggest threat
you know you were the biggest threat to
them you were gonna come back and get
them specifically and just like take
them one at a time and drain them
so
what the family members would do is that
if some if their family member died they
would do kind of like all kind of crazy
[ __ ]
to
keep them from coming back and like
eating the rest of the family
like they would cut their heads off or
they would like cut their bodies up or
you know bury the crossroads they'd bury
them like face down like you know what i
mean like straight up and down like that
so they couldn't get out they would do
that kind of or bury them face down so
they would like dig into the earth
instead of out they would do all kind of
crazy [ __ ] like that even into the like
the late 19th century into a supposedly
more enlightened era they were still
at least in rural areas i guess they
were still like thinking about this
because they thought well you know
they're gonna come back and eat us so we
better do something about that
so all the townspeople
believed they said okay well
obviously your whole family's dead so
one of your relatives who died
must be
nosferatu
so we gotta check and see which one it
is uh george brown
not real jazzed about this idea he's
just kind of i don't think he entirely
believed it at least according to the
records of the time
but because he didn't really have a
better explanation i guess he was just
kind of like okay well whatever i guess
we gotta
we gotta like kind of you know do
whatever we can do to like figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on
so he let the townspeople
go and dig up his whole entire family so
they dig up
the wife
and they dig up mary olive who was you
know his other daughter
now
uh so this was in later march like night
1892.
so they dig up the mary who was the mom
and mary olive who was the daughter she
was 20. so they opened their caskets up
and uh those two were obviously
skeletonized because they'd been in
there longer
so you know not a surprise that they
were kind of like all skeletons
so then um they decide well now we're
gonna dig up
mercy brown
who had only been dead for eight weeks
at this point oh [ __ ] she's still fresh
yeah well
so yeah so they dig her up
and um
so what ended up happening so the thing
about it is that i'm not really sure
because there's two different accounts
of this from the time period like i said
it was a long time ago
um some of the accounts said that she'd
she was buried
some of them said that the ground was
still frozen so they couldn't bury her
so she was just like in a crypt or
whatever
um so whatever the case they either dug
her up or they went to the crypt and
they moved like the lid or the coffin or
whatever
and uh
they found inside her coffin
that mercy's body
was laying on its side rather than
presumably on her back the way they had
buried her
um also her face looked like it was kind
of like you know a little pink in the
cheeks and stuff like that
uh and also still found blood in her
veins
so
like i said she'd only been dead eight
weeks which is a long time i mean she
probably was like kind of rotten and
stuff but you have to think this is new
england and it's only march
so it's still kind of cold out yeah uh
so you know she wouldn't have been like
all like
putrefied or anything like that you
would think
yeah yeah now
there was a doctor at the time dr
metcalf who
didn't like you know he was actually the
voice of reason at the time he's like he
didn't truck with this vampire nonsense
so he's like uh
look it's like she's she hasn't been
dead that long it's cold out
um you know a body doesn't decompose
that quickly in these conditions so just
everybody please calm down but of course
nobody listened to that yeah right
they're like no we want we want to kill
a vampire come on god damn it
don't spoil the fun
uh so and basically the i think that the
townspeople too were like well
we're not going to listen to the doctor
because
he could have
saved all the family from dying from
this you know this consumption disease
and he didn't do [ __ ] so obviously he
doesn't know what he's talking about
so there was that whole issue as well so
they weren't real
you know i i guess i can i can kind of
see it because maybe they thought well
medical science had failed them you know
he didn't prevent george's whole entire
family from dying of this same disease
so
you know obviously he's not really that
much of an expert so how much could he
know
so yeah so they thought well because
they're still oh thank you
because there's still blood in mercy's
heart
and veins
then that obviously meant that she was
the culprit she was the vampire although
you would think that
if she was supposedly a vampire you'd
think that the blood would be in her
stomach but i don't know maybe they
didn't really know what vampires worked
they're like no they they suck the blood
from the people and then the blood goes
into the heart that's how vampires work
obviously don't you know
so
i don't know i'm just i'm just making
[ __ ] up but yeah so she still had blood
there and she didn't look all decomposed
and rotten so they figured that she was
you know killing everybody
so basically they're like okay well this
is you know the nosferatu here so we're
gonna do something about it so they get
a bunch of firewood and uh basically
just started a big bonfire right there
in the right next to the cemetery
wherever they dug the the body up or
whatever
uh then they started they so they cut
out
mercy's heart
and they cut out her lungs you know just
uh to be on the safe side apparently
and burned them in the fire
so at this point like i said i think i
said that edwin had died he hadn't at
this point he was still alive but he was
like really really sick
so this was another thing that was
really common back then was that
if you thought that the vampire who was
your relative
was the one that was draining all the
family then you there were all these
like weird like witchcrafty kind of
spells and [ __ ] that you could do
so they cut out her heart and lungs and
burned them
and then they made like the ashes that
they got from burning her heart and
lungs
they took that and they mixed it up with
water like you do
and then they made edwin drink it yeah i
remember this [ __ ] yeah so edwin had to
drink his sister's
burned heart and lungs in water
because that was supposed to cure him
of the disease because of course makes
total sense really when you think about
it that's all they were working with
i guess so
here drink that that'll work
it's like well you know they you know
they're just trying [ __ ] yeah
uh elsa said what time of year was it it
was march so yeah and this was rhode
island so it was probably still kind of
cold yeah his refrigerating table
temperature elsa also said i saw a show
about that recently like some elderly
people in eastern europe digging up
relatives and like putting a stake
through their hearts or something from
the 2000s yeah i mean there are still
parts of the world where
they do just to be on the safe side you
never know yeah and burning parts of
them well that's what they're doing i
mean just in case i mean you never know
that relative might be a vampire right
you know a wampy or you gotta like
[ __ ] go in there and
take it out you know they're dead they
don't care
just like i said just be on the safe
side
so yeah so so they give poor edwin who's
already like sick and has been sick for
like a year and a half and is probably
just like [ __ ] this like [ __ ] my life i
hope i can [ __ ] die because i'm just
like sick of this crap but
they made him drink this horrible
concoction here drink your sister's
burned internal organs i'm sure that'll
make you feel better right
uh i think it's so funny because the the
the vampire and the wampir and all that
kind of stuff and the nosferatu that's
not the original no
the original was the stragoi
yeah
if you want to see a movie about a stock
oil go look at blood vessel that's a
good one
it's kind of a recent movie i liked it
yeah it's on shutter i think it just
came out a year or two ago yeah straight
away was a lot cooler than a vampire
they should have kept with the with the
original
yeah i mean you know i i get it that
they kind of made them all sexy and
stuff that's cool but you know i like
them more with their mozzarella i like
mozzarella stuff better destroy he's
like a rat or a bat and a demon and he
was a sorcerer
and what was funny is that he could be
either living or undead or a mixture he
could be half undead and half living he
could have children he could have
children with other stragoi he could
have children with living women and give
birth to living children he could have
sex and give
and have children with dead women
that's some [ __ ] that think of that not
even undead dead
now that's some pansexual [ __ ] yeah i'm
gonna knock this [ __ ]
that's how hot this is i'm gonna knock
this and then and it's a corpse and then
it has a child
[Laughter]
that's a [ __ ] hell of a sperm right
there
it is hellacious sperm it's magical yeah
it's contentless
have a dead woman uh had dead women give
you chill you give first give birth to
your children
jesus christ and you don't have to like
even go through any of the custody
battles or anything like that it's
win-win no
and then you piss him off and he'll
start doing some voodoo
they just start okay that's it my makeup
magic spell he's like oh and also i'm a
mummy yeah adam a mommy and a werewolf
animal
and a werewolf
not really we're saying
it's a lot better
juan asked if uh catzilla was a movie no
it's not i wish it was but uh i don't
know i just liked this uh shirt design
this little kitty gun rawr that's like i
don't know it's like
that's like kind of [ __ ] funny some
powerful sperm yeah i saw something else
that maybe that made me laugh but yeah
yeah i mean they might not be dead
either better safe than sorry yeah i'm
just you know i'm just saying so uh so
yeah so edwin uh has to drink this
concoction can you imagine can you
imagine laying in bed
feeling like absolute ass for like 18
months with tuberculosis for christ's
sake you're just like you're losing
weight you're pale you're coughing up
blood every five [ __ ] seconds
um you know you feel just terrible and
then all of a sudden they bring in this
horrible
[ __ ] that's supposed to like be magical
and make you feel better uh spoiler
alert it didn't help
he suffered for another two months after
they made him drink that crap and then
he died anyway
so
again uh was she a vampire no but
um
this actually
this was the last time that this
happened in new england but it happened
previous to this
what happened there was one case and it
was also in rhode island in 1799
and i think it was the same town too
exeter so this town has a problem with
believing in vampires i don't know so
1799 there was this woman named sarah
tillinghast
and she had died and for whatever reason
everybody thought she was a vampire too
um so they dug her ass up
and that's kind of like one of the first
ones i guess i was like reading this
thing where there was this historian and
she said because there's a thing that's
called like the new england vampire
panic and for what it was kind of like
the salem witch trials was like 200
years later where
mostly because of the tuberculosis
plague that kind of went through the
area at the time there was kind of like
this little mini boomlet of everybody
thinking that that was [ __ ] vampires
you know what i mean so there was kind
of uh there were 18 documented cases
there might have been some that were not
documented
um but there were 18 documented cases of
family members digging up their other
family members who had died previously
because they thought that that family
member was like walking around at night
and like draining people's blood and
[ __ ] like that like from the other
family members
um
so yeah so what ended up happening with
mercy brown
after they cut her heart out and lungs
and made her poor brother drink it they
ended up um you know burying her again
like without her heart and her tombstone
is still there you can see it
i used the photograph of it in the in
the whatever for this the thumbnail
um and also like i said it's
that there's just this okay so there was
this other dude
uh and this also happened in rhode
island i don't know what the [ __ ]
wrong with rhode island anybody's from
there just like let me know there was
this other dude named william rose who
lived in rhode island and this was
a little bit before that it was like
1874.
and his daughter juliet died i don't
know if it was tuberculosis it might
have been some other sickness or
something that kind of mimicked that um
i didn't realize it wasn't really
recorded
now uh so so juliet died and then she
had a sister named mary and mary also
died with what looked like the same
thing so i'm presuming it's probably
like
tuberculosis um but instead of thinking
see it's it's so weird to me that they
didn't think at the time
you know oh we all live in the same
house we're all like sharing the same
germs
and i guess that wasn't really like
something that was that would occur to
them i mean it seems very obvious to us
nowadays but maybe it wasn't because
it's like
you know you live in the same house you
get the same diseases right so juliet
dies and then mary gets sick with what
seems like the same thing the first
thing that dad jumps to is that oh
juliet must be coming back from the
grave and draining her life energy
because of course that's the first thing
you would think because that's the more
obvious thing i mean i don't know that's
like [ __ ] i don't understand it so
so he goes
um
to juliet's grave to check out this
situation
and apparently he said
that he saw juliet's ghost floating
above the grave almost kind of like
that's right dad come get it you know
what i mean yeah i'm doing that
this is what he said anyway i i think
he's making [ __ ] up
um
so so at that point he sees the ghost
there he says
so he digs up her grave
and he said that when he dug her up
this is his daughter by the way he dug
her up and her body was all covered with
blood for some reason so obviously she's
a vampire
uh so again he did the same thing he cut
her heart out and burned it
now in this case it worked mary got
better
so obviously that dude was like never
disabused of his
superstition because he's like oh see i
took care of the situation
my other daughter was coming and feeding
on my younger daughter so i went cut the
heart out and i fixed it because now my
daughter's better and it's fine well
[ __ ] happens within the mind
yeah
and i'm sure obviously it was just a
coincidence that that happened but you
know because some people did recover
from tuberculosis it's just that it was
rare it was rare most people did die
from it honestly nowadays like
every time you see i'm thinking of that
movie uh moulin rouge
i remember the first time that i saw
that in the theater
the second somebody coughs and there's
like a little drop of blood in a
handkerchief i'm like oh they're dead
yeah that's you know that that was like
shorthand for that person's dead now
because tuberculosis
although you know what's funny is that
um
they
based on what i know about nutrition and
everything and [ __ ] what i don't
think that tuberculosis
would kill modern people at the rate
that it killed people from that era
i mean they had very low protein diets
the hygiene was kind of bad
um it was not a very they were kind of
weakened to begin with they they
they died from [ __ ] and also just not
knowing you know what i mean just basic
[ __ ]
i think helped add to the mortality of
[ __ ] [ __ ] tuberculosis a lot you
know they would do things to me they
thought would cure them that was not
making it worse you know bloodletting
and [ __ ] like that yeah i mean you know
i'm and it's weird because i mean
obviously it's easy to like make fun of
people from our time because it's like
we know so much more than they know
but a lot of the [ __ ] they did a lot of
the [ __ ] they did i can understand like
how they got from point a to point b
even though it's dumb and wrong
but some of the [ __ ] they did i just
didn't
i don't know
it's hard because we grew up knowing
germs cons cause disease
um you know don't breathe on other
people don't you know wash your hands do
this kind of stuff so it seems
obvious
well also a sick person you want to wash
their bed clothes and [ __ ] bathe them
a lot and you know
keep them from [ __ ] you know what i
mean get rid of [ __ ] open sewage from
the [ __ ] room which like i said which
i mean that would seem like [ __ ] yeah
self-evident no it would be underneath
that bed would be a [ __ ] chamber pot
full of turds and piss and all kinds of
[ __ ] and flies would be flying around in
there
they they they were dirty you know even
when they didn't really know it i mean
animals don't even do that yeah and then
they were
eating food that was bad unsanitary bad
cleaning practices
cooking [ __ ] with [ __ ] dirty hands
and just
not to say the [ __ ] tb isn't deadly
tb is a [ __ ] deadly disease it is no
one's saying that their practices made
it less survivable made everything less
survivable i'd imagine just with basic
knowledge
of a [ __ ] hygiene and how
medicine works and how it doesn't work
you know i mean like bloodletting does
not work drinking [ __ ] caustic
chemicals doesn't work
you probably would have saved a lot more
people had you just done nothing just
kept them clean and well fed and let
them rest
probably saved a lot of them and
honestly you were not the first person
to say that i've i've heard like many
historians and writers and stuff they
said you know what it's like some of the
[ __ ] that they did like prior to them
figuring out the germ theory of disease
they said honestly it probably would
have been better just like leave those
people and not touch them because a lot
of the [ __ ] that they did to him was
making it worse
yeah
i mean
a truly deadly disease is only usually
about 30 failure fatal and that's
[ __ ] deadly well thirty percent
that's pretty good odds
but not with the medicine they had back
then that was i'm like hey made it worse
let me rub my hand on my ass and then
like yeah yeah reach around in your
insides yeah you might move more you
might move mortality up to 70 percent
under those conditions
you know so it would not have been the
same disease to tuberculosis
had it been under under normal modern
conditions
yeah i mean
like we said before and i was talking
about i think i was talking about the
last show because i said i re had reread
uh drewd which was set in uh victorian
era london and they he kind of talks
about in that book like the great stink
and everything like that where the
streets were just even where the upper
class people lived everything was just
lined with sewage everything was just
like [ __ ] like horseshit human [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] everything was just [ __ ] and
everything stunk
and um
you know and there were dead bodies
floating in the thames everybody just
threw like chemicals and crap and
everything just everything in the thames
and everything smelled terrible and no
one really did anything about it
everyone was like well that's just the
way it goes no one thought to like not
do that they cooked and canned rotten
meat along with the good meat yeah and
sold that
you know oh it'd be all right
yeah
the mentality of the arrow was not the
same i'm honestly shocked that any of
them lived past 30.
you know to me i don't like i don't
how did they survive even like the
i mean i guess like living in filth uh
kind of like ups your immune system to a
degree
yeah there's diminishing returns though
but yeah up to a point yeah up to a
point um you know there comes a point
where and [ __ ] we've seen this in the
modern day like on hoarders and stuff
where you live in a house that's just
like filled with [ __ ] like your [ __ ] cat
[ __ ] rats mice roaches um you know
eventually that's gonna kill you there's
some [ __ ] i want to say without
triggering any kind of [ __ ] ai
algorithms i don't know but
there's a certain amount of there's a
thing that they do to people where you
take a weakened a weakened disease and
insert it into your system and your
system learns from that and it's called
it starts with a v and with that you
gain acquired immunity
okay
that is a technology that does work but
also taking the same person and putting
them in kind of a half dirty environment
in contact with these diseases you can
acquire immunity that way in the same
way
instead of being bombarded with an
intense amount of these
viral particles you only get some of
them a little bit at a time
and you can your body can actually learn
to kind of gain an immunity from that
too
so the v
i'm going to just call it the v
theory is is it does work but there's
also an a natural thing that does work
they both work
um
it just depends on what disease it is
and the situation now does it you just
sitting around you gain immunity no
that
you can't really trust that
with the v theory you could probably
trust that a little bit more as long as
it's
it's the right disease and it's done
right
in the past preservatives and chemicals
were added to that system
or things that weren't quite
done right and it didn't work or
kill people when it shouldn't have
but each one is its own
special case
they both can work
but i have noticed growing up in the
developing world
in brazil
people that have no medical care no
history of medical care living in
favelas
or just shiny towns
amazing constitutions
amazing
they could eat things that would just
make you [ __ ] puke and they can eat
it and live off of it well you have to
think that most of the people that would
have died from that have already died
yeah so it's like a natural selection
process
but they're a lot healthier than you
think they are i mean there's some i
don't know people say you know brazilian
jeans you know growing up in brazil
brazilians are gifted to a certain
extent you know what i mean [ __ ] they
got them girls got some fantastic booty
but they also had [ __ ] very strong
constitutions
when i was there there was a plague and
it's probably still going on there's a
plague
of [ __ ] um i forgot what it's called
and it was making them [ __ ] be risk
takers they were [ __ ] crazy make them
drive like [ __ ] nuts
they [ __ ] all thought they were race
car drivers they would take [ __ ]
sexual risks and risks it was just
[ __ ]
and they they made them party real hard
and it was a it was a it was worms that
got into their brain microscopic little
worms
and they would be attract it came from
cat piss
oh yeah yeah they all had that a lot of
not all of them but
at least half of them had it what's that
[ __ ] called those myo max and
something like uh what was this [ __ ]
because i thought they had it with like
rabbits toxic plasmosis there you go
toxoplasmosis or something like that
when i was there
[ __ ] there was a plague of toxopla
toxoplasmosis
and um
the wildest [ __ ] and the
hottest girls all had that [ __ ]
they did they put out like a heartbeat
and a wild man and [ __ ] the the acid
test is whether or not you're repelled
by the smell of cat piss if you like the
smell of cat piss you got it
yeah that's toxoplasmosis
it's a good thing i passed that test i
don't like to smell cat piss yeah that's
most normal people don't yeah
a lot of [ __ ] that went down in carnival
and [ __ ] winning race car and
badass race car drivers and
brazilian porn stars did [ __ ]
damn
[Laughter]
it's not a fatal disease in most cases i
don't think they they treat it you know
but they make them [ __ ] wild man make
it wow well yeah you might die doing
other [ __ ] yeah die from being a risk
taker that's what i mean yeah you know
obviously your odds go way up then yeah
hyper sexuality they're super macho
super feminine [ __ ] sexually
aggressive [ __ ] uh they do everything
fast uh
you wanna gamble [ __ ] uh winner take
all [ __ ] bet and everything on a
single bet you know just that's it
that's it yeah crazy yeah
i was thinking too about uh when we were
talking about one one one of the best
books that i ever read that was like a
nonfiction book i think it was called
the speckled monster
and it was about how
the smallpox vaccine was discovered um
and it's like it's a fascinating
fascinating story it's a long book but
it was like it was really good i was
just like riveted uh how that kind of
worked out how they figured out um you
know what caused it and [ __ ] because
like i said for a long time they didn't
they didn't really get on board with
that whole germ theory it's like well we
can't see germs so it's like magic well
they didn't really believe in it you
know what i mean so it took him a long
time to get to that and i think i've
mentioned before there was another book
called the ghost map which was all about
uh it wasn't dysentery it was cholera
cholera uh how they found out that that
like microorganisms in the water
like i said don't drink [ __ ] water
which seems self-evident but not so much
uh in the 19th century so how they
figured that out too and how the guy
that came up with it's like hey don't
drink [ __ ] water nobody's like what are
you crazy we like drinking [ __ ] water
you know he's like no seriously it's
causing diseases and everybody's dying
but um another thing too is that
what people and i they might still do it
nowadays but i remember when i was a kid
because remember how bitter get
chickenpox right like every school year
when you were a kid
um you know everybody would get
chickenpox it would go around the
[ __ ] school
i had it but very very mild um i have a
really
genetically i've you know there's a lot
of genetic things i don't like about
myself but i actually really do have a
very very good immune system
uh so i never get like flus go around
colds go around [ __ ] i'll get it maybe
but like a very very minor variant and
the same thing happened when i was a kid
chickenpox went around my brother got it
so bad that his face swelled up and he
still had scars from it like a long time
afterward i got it and it was like half
a day and i was kind of like got three
spots and i was kind of like okay
whatever i look in the back and victor
garcia jump so toxoplasmosis yeah
he's got that [ __ ] latino name well
he's a nurse yeah but all he's all down
central south americans you know know
all about toxoplasmosis
i think some of that damn latino [ __ ]
reputation kind of might come from
partially from the effects of [ __ ]
having a high rate of time i would
explain a lot yeah actually it's not
deadly [ __ ] for the most most cases
and it's just
make you [ __ ] wild
yeah
brain worms they're very microscopic
though you know what i mean they just
[ __ ]
do something to you you guys it's
documented you can see
well i mean that it happens to other
animals too like yeah like little worm
like they'll get like in a little ant
brain and be like hey do whatever you
know what i mean it came from the favela
that's pretty freaky that's like a
[ __ ] cronenberg movie right there
came from the five fellow there were
humans cats and rats all living in the
same area and there isn't real goods
there isn't really any sewage
system going on there you know it's all
manual carrying everything out and
[ __ ] buckets and containers and
[ __ ] throw it in the river
and uh yep there's crosstalk
contamination
there's fleas and [ __ ] rats and
[ __ ] mice and infected rats and cats
and
they're all living in the same area and
[ __ ] it can get into the human
population
which is something in north america they
don't know anything about it
yeah hell yeah although like i said i
kind of feel like maybe with hoarders
and stuff yeah
well because their houses are filled
with like rats a lot of them have like
cats living in there and they just like
dogs and cats and stuff just like poop
all over the place in there
and also roaches i think john lyden had
it
remember he said the [ __ ] rats used
to piss on his little kid and it caused
his brain to swell up [ __ ]
and after that he became a punk rocker
you remember that
so that explains punk rock i think puck
rock was the [ __ ] toxic rats piss on
us
i'm pretty sure rat never pissed on me
when i was a baby well uh no he wasn't
bad he was a baby he's a teenager he
says you couldn't do anything about it
in those council estates they were
filled with mice and rats they'd be
piddling all over your clothes and all
over your bed sheets there's nothing you
can do about it and you didn't know it
and it's like he got a real
bad fever and his brain swelled up and
[ __ ] i remember him saying something
yeah and then after that he just got he
said [ __ ] it you know what i mean and
then he went down that path and that
sounds something like toxoplasmosis i
think
yeah he was a wild [ __ ] too john
lyden was the [ __ ] he was
although that [ __ ] spent now
he's old he spends all of his time
talking about himself back in the 70s
i kind of feel like that happens to a
lot of old people yeah they're like kind
of trying to and i and i hate it because
i saw like when i was younger and i used
to see the you know old people when you
know when i was young and they were old
and they'd be like back in my day
brother and i'm just like holy crap oh
my god and it's like nobody likes that
it's like it's like no one cares about
which show you were like but i so i try
not to do that i know i probably do at
some points
you know back in the day blah blah blah
i don't know i really try not to do that
but he appeared in a time when it didn't
take much to change [ __ ]
that's true so yeah he you know he goes
off by how important he was he was kind
of important for his time he wasn't an
important person really he was just the
right man in the right place at the
right time
honestly i think
that if you're a really important person
then other people will say you're
important yeah but he said you come out
saying i'm important it's like
everyone's like man shut up you douche
yeah
what was it jimmy seville was the guy
was the name jimmy sevilla he went on
his show and [ __ ] embarrassed him and
that's and that's how that's that pedo
yeah yeah
somebody asked us to do a show about him
actually a couple of people asked us i
probably will at some point yeah that's
kind of because that's a really famous
case in the uk yeah and didn't john
wasn't that john lyden and [ __ ] susie
on his show and weren't getting i can't
remember what was that show jimmy
seville i think it was uh yeah i can't
remember he called him an old [ __ ]
yeah remember that you dirty old [ __ ]
and he was dirty oh [ __ ] turned out
yeah they called it his kids saw right
through that [ __ ] yeah everybody told
suzie says look me and you we'll meet
afterwards okay
i always wanted to meet you oh we'll
meet afterwards you dirty [ __ ] you
dirty oh [ __ ] around alive tell them
it's okay [ __ ] you kids
that would have been funny if she said
i've always wanted to meet you so i
could punch you right in the dick
after a pause it was a baby susie that
was [ __ ] she was super cute she's still
super cute yeah
honestly i haven't seen her in a while
but like last time i saw her she's got
to be [ __ ] old as [ __ ] now but she's
used to something she still looks good
though she feels good yeah i thought
[ __ ] man we were i was in burger king
last night
we stopped at burger king on the way to
the movies and uh they had what
entertainment tonight or whatever the
[ __ ] that show is and the elvira was on
there cassandra peterson she was on
there and it's like that [ __ ] is like
70 something years old
and she still looks fit [ __ ] she's
she's getting for that though and she
worked for them well obviously yeah i
mean obviously it's surgery yes but well
it's work too and drugs
yeah she's taking the right stuff
mega says please don't do a show about
jimmy smith
i'm just saying something i don't
remember who it was it was a long time
ago but somebody else
from the american perspective there were
a lot of british personalities from the
70s and 80s that are fascinating to us
because we knew about them but we didn't
grow up with them they weren't in our
media we only heard about them through
rock stars that we liked because then
and because i was like into new wave and
post punk and stuff i was a total like
anglophile like i used to love like all
the british tv from back in the day i
was like i said i was even married to a
british person for like 15 years so it's
like so and i lived over there for a
little while so it's like i knew a lot
more i guess about british culture than
the average american we knew about your
culture but we didn't have an intimate
knowledge of we didn't grow up in it it
was an alien culture yeah it's well it's
always different yeah because you're
just like seeing it through the prism of
their media yeah right and it's like you
know somebody growing up in a place
that's never going to be the same as
right then yeah you know when you're
seeing it from afar same thing europeans
you know what i mean again they see what
happens in america they know what
happened but they don't quite see it the
same way we did because
they're not living in the same
environment so the context is different
and the thing about america too is that
it's such a huge country
yeah yeah so it's like if something
happened in like one city somewhere it's
like that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's the same attitude that people
would have about it in other places
because between california and florida
is the difference between france and and
germany or france and england it just
happens to be that we we speak the same
language and to be honest it's like not
even that it's kind of like in some
states it's like county to county county
county yeah you know what i mean it's
it's so it's so you can't just say oh
california does this or new york does
this because it's like there's lots of
different there's going to be some
counties here in florida that resemble
counties in [ __ ]
california there's gonna be weird [ __ ]
like that that's what i mean this is a
massive massive place and it's just kind
of like it shits all over the [ __ ]
map yeah just
people that do not grow up in the united
states a lot of foreigners also depends
on the generation you're talking about
see the united states as a unite a
single united country
americans in general don't really see it
that way we see it more like the way you
would see the eu
i mean we kind of do but not really more
like not really it's more like an
imperium
each state is its own country kind of
like in the eu but there's a centralized
government that nobody really agrees
with
or you know what i mean it's
and like i said you know i've lived in
different it's almost kind of like
because i live in florida there's some
counties here that are better than other
counties yeah uh you know and this and
that's kind of the same everywhere so
it's it's very very localized
i kind of feel like that's good because
you can vote with your feet if you're in
a bad county you can get the [ __ ] out of
there joe nash said it was the bill
grundy show yeah it was funny okay yeah
i was pretty sure it wasn't the jimmy
seville thing yeah bill clinton because
that was a whole other issue bill grundy
he seemed to me to be kind of like the
merv griffin of england
you know merv griffin was the elevator
killer yeah griffin was actually cool
though he was actually
actually cool yeah
that's why well that's why i was so
excited when i saw him like in the man
with two brains i'm like that he
actually like played a serial killer and
he's like
i've just always liked killing i just
really really enjoyed it
and i was like oh my god that dude's
awesome
so yeah that made me happy but yeah i
kind of feel like well
it was pretty easy i guess it was pretty
easy in the u.s too but it was like
pretty easy to like piss off
the squares back then yeah so you just
like go on a show and say [ __ ]
and everyone's like in the uk or in the
u.s at that time period everyone was
gonna like have a [ __ ] [ __ ] fit about
it
which is funny because it's hilarious
nowadays
it's hilarious because it's nothing
looking back in the 70s because the 70s
was a [ __ ] time of [ __ ]
swingers motels and all kinds of weird
tea parties there was part there were
parts of the [ __ ] parts of the united
states during the 70s was like something
out of [ __ ] logan's run
other parts of it was like some other
cowboy movie it just didn't make any god
well honestly we recorded we recorded uh
a review today the rocky horror picture
show which came out in 1975 and it's
like look at the [ __ ] that was going on
in that movie in the 70s but then like
on the other side of it
you know as wild as that movie was you
had like these really super uptight
yeah honestly i kind of feel like the
70s was kind of more freewheeling like
the 80s kind of went more uptight 80s
started to because the 80s got like
super uptight right
i mean i and i kind of remember that
transition become very corporate
i mean you know i was a kid but i
remember that it had to do with money
and yuppies yeah people started to make
a lot of money so they tried to [ __ ]
be
like respectable i think
in a very middle class class and
returning back to kind of like
a traditional kind of in a way
upstandingness
in general but that was like the the
gestalt were people doing that no
no see that's the thing it's like it's
always kind of like [ __ ] and like that's
something else i was gonna say because
victor said where key parties real see i
don't really know i think in the 70s
they were but i mean certain people yeah
but i think it was like pretty small
yeah it was sub culture i think it was
kind of a thing it was the fetish
parties yeah it was kind of a thing
where now
you know our fetish party's real yeah is
is it like a mass market like a no no
it's a very very stable we can tell you
who it is yeah and [ __ ] where all
that [ __ ] is we know them they're all
married couples and they're like lawyers
yeah and lawyers that meet yeah like we
know that's going on but it's not
mainstream no it's not something it's a
pretty small like subculture and i think
probably the same thing and i think key
parties are just known nowadays because
in hindsight because of this yeah
because it's like a few people were
doing it and it got around and it was
like oh that's so naughty so like we're
talking about that like look how [ __ ]
wild the 70s were yeah so i kind of feel
most people are just doing normal [ __ ]
like i kind of feel like most people are
doing normal [ __ ] all the time it's just
that there's these outliers that are
doing some crazy [ __ ] somebody hears
about it and reports on it and then
suddenly your whole decade gets
associated
with this one
this thing that maybe one percent of the
population we're doing you know the
fetish scene right now in our area is
dominated by throuples we call them
throuples that's couples of three
it's usually one it's one guy and two
girls usually sometimes think this might
be
yeah well so yeah it might be i don't
think there's any two guys in one girl
thing
i don't know any i mean i'm sure there
are some but i don't know any personally
there are
male and female couples that are in open
relationships that we know yeah i know a
lot of those yeah where the dude is like
yeah she's out having fun with him it's
all right you know what i mean [ __ ]
this and that and it but they're just
kind of doing it what's funny is that
they tend to be popular everybody knows
who they are they don't tend to be like
real good looking not all of them some
of them are
but like one of them is a couple
it's a lawyer
with her husband her husband was an
ex-defendant and an ex-con that she
represented one time he's pretty cool
too and then their girlfriend
and they go out and dance a [ __ ]
party
um they're wild they are funny they're
nice people they're they're they're very
nice i've known them forever yeah and
they got teenage girls that live with
them t they're their daughters or is it
just one daughter they have a daughter
they have a daughter and it's her friend
well no she's not a teenager she's
probably 20. she's 20 now but i remember
when she was a teenager it was so funny
because the daughter knew what was going
on and she just thought it was
ridiculous she thought it was like well
it's her parents her parents she's like
oh that's like it's whatever your
parents are doing even if like from our
point of view it's like cool or whatever
it's like if that's your parents you'll
be like lame and i thought [ __ ] was lame
i was like cooking so embarrassing we
had a party over there their place i was
cooking pizza and [ __ ] and everyone's
over and uh it was
that couple with their girlfriend and
and she was living in a room up there
with them and it's just
it might sound weird if you didn't know
them
when you know them it's like well of
course
and it's not weird really when you know
them it's not weird they're not weird
no they're they're funny
they're awesome i love that i love those
too i love you know i love those two
actually we just saw them it was just
the last time we went to mannequins they
go out all the time it doesn't it it
seems weird if you were just like
putting on people you don't really know
but when you know i'm you're like oh
yeah of course well it's just like
everything else it's like if there's
something you don't like know about or
experience yourself yeah it seems weird
but then like when you know people do
it's not it's totally not weird yeah
everybody's like okay whatever yeah like
i said we've known them forever
we've been to their house they had a
birthday party for me a couple years ago
it's like you know yeah and the
girlfriend was was a
girl that we knew and dated some of our
friends and she was cute too and
the girlfriend be yelling at the
daughter you better never saw that [ __ ]
and she's like i'll [ __ ] you the the
girlfriend's trying to [ __ ]
discipline the daughter about doing [ __ ]
in the house
trying to keep her ass in line so
imagine that
not only but like i said whenever with
your parents girlfriend right
who's
it wasn't weird to her because she'd
grown up in that house so it's like it's
not weird to her but like i said when
you're a teenager everything your
parents do is embarrassing yeah
everything the girlfriend was probably
about six to eight years older than her
which has probably pissed her off yeah
[ __ ] i ain't doing that [ __ ] right oh
you better [ __ ] clean that [ __ ] are
you crazy
well and the thing is like we know
another couple too who you know
they're not like you know they're not uh
swingers or whatever you want to call it
but they're you know they've been in the
god scene a long time and they have a
couple daughters that are older they're
like teenagers and ones in their 20s
and
for a while while the daughter was
mid-teens
uh the daughter was kind of like
rebelling she's like man she's going to
get into like hip-hop and stuff like
that because this goth thing you guys oh
my god yeah yeah mom you're too old to
be looking like that and it was just
like this whole thing and she was like
lashing out and like
getting in all kind of trouble and stuff
she's grown out of it now here's the
funny thing the mom is is like a
beautiful goth
woman who is a singer for a bad
background singer
the daughter looks like a young
now we remember last time i started she
was a little kid now she's old enough to
go to the club and she looks like she
will be in a couple months yeah she
looks like a [ __ ] super hot little
tick tocker [ __ ] type chick it's just
funny they grew up fast
but um
yeah it's weird
well now like i said the daughter it's
for a time she was just like you guys
are so lame it's like you guys are so
old and why is she dressing like that
now she's a cop chick and now yeah she
got over it though yeah because i mean
you know reproduction reproduction mom
used to tell me she's like man she makes
fun of me all the time she's like and
you know her mom is like she's younger a
little bit younger than me yeah and she
knows she's like in her early to mid 40s
and she's still i mean she looks really
young and she's really beautiful and she
has like the whole goth look at
everything back here yeah and she's kind
of like you know my daughter told me
that i was too old to be looking like
this and it's like why do you leave the
house looking like this it's so
embarrassing and also their kind of
stuff and it's like it was this whole
thing but like she's grown out of it now
because like i said anything your
parents do is lame when you're a
teenager that's just the way it goes i
think it's been like that since time
immemorial even if your parents are cool
by everyone else's standards
to your teenage kid you can never be
cool you can never be cool that's who
we're talking about in the red corset
yeah i'm not gonna show the daughter
though well yeah that would be weird
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
that would be weird but yeah they have a
couple of kids yeah well she has a
couple of kids there's one with her and
her husband and one she had from a
previous relationship
but yeah the daughter got over it though
she was kind of a troublemaker
in her teenage years but you know what
are you gonna do yeah
yeah sort of they were talking about
like uh [ __ ] yeah we got cash app
right you got a cash app
uh
yes we're gonna send the money to some
money to keith
later on later on okay for some stuff
ilsa says who's the girl on the right
that's laura that was laura she's
another friend of ours yeah that's laura
yeah
she uh yeah me and uh that's that's jen
i guess we can say yeah lauren she's in
13th angel yeah so uh yeah me and me and
jen and laura
are in like a bunch of photos bunch of
photos of the [ __ ] that they've done
yeah but we go and hang out every now
and then
although i haven't seen uh i haven't
seen laura in a while i'm just going to
come out last night she's coming out
okay i know but she always says that
yeah i saw her like a while back me and
her and jen went down to downtown
samford and hung out
dj maniac says uh telling ilsa come to
red party next month the starry night is
playing and you'll get to meet me
who said that
dj mania okay yeah that's new york city
right new york they're coming yeah
that's right yeah starry night's gonna
be up there
all right so where was i can i get back
to the [ __ ] get back to the show all
right well we're good we got a good
people amount of people in there
following right now
okay that's good well we're done with
the vampire [ __ ] mostly i mean like i
said that was kind of a thing there was
like a little mini boob boomlet
in uh
new england in the late 19th century
because of tuberculosis probably
for for whatever reason at least 18
people thought their family members were
vampires
and dug them up
and burned their hearts and
did [ __ ] like that because they thought
that would solve the problem and uh
mercy brown was the last one that that
happened to so like i said you can still
see your grave it's in extra rhode
island if you want to visit it
so you know
all right so let's talk about
the cleary changeling case which i had
actually never heard of until i saw it
on this show i don't remember what the
show was called but it was one of those
kind of like weird world paranormal
whatever
uh it was either on tubey or amazon or
netflix or whatever and i was watching
it was like a documentary and they did
like reenactments of it and i was like
oh my god this is like a fascinating
case i'm gonna have to like do that on
the show because that's really
interesting so this is like a murder
case but there's also kind of like
a weird like paranormal element to it
so this happened in 1895
in ireland
so there's this woman named bridget
cleary
and she was married to this dude
named michael
and he was a cooper i had to look up
what that was do you know what that is a
cooper it's a job but i forgot what it
is well i know it's a job something with
uh
taking care of pigeons or some [ __ ]
like that or no you're like heads in the
stones or
way off well that's what i mean that's
why i was like i gotta google that [ __ ]
because i'm not actually sure what that
is
um it's somebody that makes
wooden barrels okay like wooden stuff
out of timber stations yeah and they had
to wrap it with them yeah yeah yeah
that's right that was yeah that's
because that was a huge industry back up
new barrel makers yeah they had to make
a barrel see i didn't know i had to look
it up huge industry yeah that would be
like the equivalent of today
making refrigerators
because that's what you were storing
fluids and foods yeah everybody needed
barrels yeah it was
food storage somebody had to make that
[ __ ] yeah and that's what her husband
did
uh so okay so like i said this is 1895.
now so he worked as a cooper
and uh you know from all accounts
uh at least prior to
whatever happened happened
uh they were supposedly very happy and
they were also quite
prosperous now they didn't have any kids
but they lived in a cottage near
temporary temporary
with bridget's dad
now
michael was a quite a bit older than
bridget nine years which i guess that's
not that huge of a deal
um
so he kind of made some good money
and actually she made quite a bit of
good money too uh she kept chickens so
she sold eggs and she was also a
seamstress and i believe she also worked
as a milliner like she made hats and
stuff so she actually like made a pretty
good living too which
not unusual but would have been kind of
unusual for a woman to be making almost
as much as her husband at that time i
guess
because that was something that got
brought up a lot later on
uh so they were kind of like not wealthy
wealthy but a little bit richer than
their neighbors were because she was
making a bunch of extra money on the
side
um she was also literate which a lot of
women weren't at the time uh and dressed
real fashionable which was something
that a lot of people commented on
because you know even though she was
working class you know people uh you
know
commented on it i guess
so at this point so this is ireland
now at this time period in ireland maybe
nowadays i don't think so
but back then
i kind of feel like there was a very
widespread belief in
fairies
not like you're good like tinkerbell
kind of fairies
but
you know like little people type fairies
who are
not necessarily evil
but
not necessarily good
either you know what i mean
uh irish people were probably like a
test
that
like some [ __ ] it was like some [ __ ] out
of [ __ ] dungeons and dragons or out
of like the hobbit
they're talking about other races of
humanity like sub humans and demi humans
and weird [ __ ] you know like a
leprechaun
[ __ ] fairies yeah kind of like
leprechauns which i kind of feel like
in the u.s we kind of have a thing well
like we know what leprechauns are but i
kind of feel like nowadays we have like
lucky charms and all that kind of [ __ ]
so it's kind of been filtered down into
something cheap into something that oh
yay happy leprechauns with their
pots of gold and [ __ ] like that but
i guess like in the home country in
ireland because you know like obviously
us has a huge like irish influence
because there was a lot of irish
immigration back in the day
but
um leprechauns and fairies and [ __ ] like
that were not really anything to be
[ __ ] around with no like i said they
weren't evil but you didn't want to get
on the wrong side of that magical
abilities and sure yeah this goes back
you know to like the nibble long and
german stuff you know the main [ __ ]
dwarves that can make magical rings
token came from all this token was
inspired bali's
all this lore
and he would write all these stories and
from that came dungeons and dragons and
all this
[ __ ] in the modern era you know [ __ ]
game of thrones and all that you know
that's where they come from but but what
was weird
is that they actually believed in this
[ __ ] to a certain extent
there were people trying to photograph
them
there were also
i rem uh in one of those mysteries of
the unexplained books that i had
they actually had segments that were
lifted out of magazine or newspapers
from
the 1800s
that claimed archaeologists had were
digging or workmen were digging and they
found broke into a miniature tunnel that
was like everything was one-quarter
proportions of normal human beings
little bitty doors little stairwells
rooms little furniture and they they
follow them as far as they could you
know but then like you know the trail
went cold and they never didn't find
anything that kind of [ __ ]
and i was like at the time i'm reading
this and i'm going what the [ __ ] are
they talking about
you know what i mean i didn't have the
cultural context at the time i was
reading this in the 90s this is what
they're talking about they're talking
about fairies yeah okay fairies and
leprechauns our little elves and [ __ ]
and
these reports of breaking into these
underground under
you know [ __ ] underground caverns
with little bitty tunnels and [ __ ] and
and the stories are given like
like they're straight like it's real
news
it's fake news though it was up there
with like the uh
airship stories
yeah and uh you know i think people
don't realize that people hundreds of
years ago also also liked trolling they
trolled the [ __ ] out of people and would
publish stories and newspapers that were
absolutely [ __ ] absolutely [ __ ]
but were written as though they were
real yeah another one was [ __ ] like um
people found coal or stone and they were
breaking it apart and a frog jumped out
yeah we did a show about that and in the
middle of the stone was a place where
the frog could [ __ ] hide and when
they put the frog back on the stone it
went right back into there and it
preferred to be in the stone and all of
its orifices would seal up like it had a
mouth but it had sealed up it had a butt
hole but it had sealed up it was totally
self and you're and have a butt hole
yeah yeah so i'm reading this in my
early 20s going [ __ ] yeah there's
some weird [ __ ] in this world man
[ __ ] these [ __ ]
back in the day they were finding weird
[ __ ] you know and they'd have a whole
bunch of these stories
in a whole section of this book that i
read called mysteries unexplained yeah i
had a book like that people were
throwing coal into the fire and frogs
jumping out and they were hey that's my
housemate yeah and they would [ __ ]
look and they see a piece of coal and
the frog had jumped out of the center of
the cold it was perfect and it doesn't
make sense to a modern person you're
like why the [ __ ] they can't be making
that up because that doesn't mean
anything
yeah it meant something it meant
something and that's something the
cultural context cultural context is
freudian fordian archaeology
charles ford we did a whole show about
14 and 40 and our 14 archaeology the
reason why they were coming up with this
weird [ __ ] anachronisms living frogs it
was kind of a creationist it was about
creationism thing yeah
they were trying to
use these stories to fortify their
belief in the bible yep that the earth
is not that old that's that's but you
see that would be totally lost on on a
on a person in 20. i mean there's still
creationists around nowadays but it's a
very very fringe belief that would still
be lost on it yeah so mainstream belief
they'd be like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about yeah why would somebody
make that why would they make that up
that must have happened no it didn't
happen they're trying to say that the
word that the worth was it's
it's it's uh creationism yeah
there it's only six thousand it's only
six thousand years old and the the the
the rocks that you are saying are
thousands of years old are not thousands
of years old they're a couple hundred
years old that's what they're saying
yeah that's what they're saying
it's just it's just really funny that
yeah such a long ago but like i said
it's it just goes to show that it
doesn't take long for the whole cultural
context of something to be lost right
like i said that was the whole thing
about when we were watching that
industrial short last night and the
whole thing about the dude eating
tomatoes like an apple like from a fruit
basket and i'm like is there something
i'm missing out of this like who the
[ __ ] does that nobody
i was like and why are they harping on
it it's so weird because they kept
saying a second tomato
and a tomato goes
and you were saying maybe it's like
because tomatoes like a slang from like
a hot girl i was like yeah i know that
but it's like that's a long way to go
around they kept shell on a hot his
daughter was
she was what you would call it a day a
pog a fat that's white girl okay she
wearing little pedal purse pushers
and [ __ ] pointed bra
and a booty back in the 50s she would
have been she'd have been a pug she was
a tomato they kept showing the tomato
and her in the tomato and they were
making tomato jokes
because they're trying to get these
workers to watch this to pay attention
pay attention to this [ __ ] safety
look don't get your face knot off yeah
by the machine by the machine so they
keep showing this
fast
pay attention 16 year old 17 year old
fat ass white girl that's running around
in her fat
well it's fat with the p p h a t okay
yeah yeah pog you got it that's why you
got it yeah thick
too thick well you should have said that
should you think thick with two c's no
no
okay dick with two c's yeah t-h-i-c-c
yeah that's what i said yeah
although she wouldn't be thick by
today's standards she was that's what i
mean she was sick for the she was stick
for the 50 to the 50s
another thing we were commenting on too
was that the dude that got his fingers
knot off by the machine and his wife
um
how old were they supposed to be because
they looked 40s
god damn 40s the wife particularly she
looked like she was about 75.
you got married you got married in your
late teens by today's standards you got
married in your late teens
so they were in their late 30s or early
40s because the girl was maybe 16 17.
rode hard and put up wet back yeah gotta
say well their lifestyle was different
and they drank a lot and they ate like
[ __ ] and they didn't get my sleep
and they worked very hard
in the 50s
mainstream america was kind of in the
place it was a developing nation back
then kind of in the place where like
middle class china is right now and all
the time all the dudes were so dumpy
dumpy
low tea
high fat [ __ ] eating a lot of
[ __ ] they [ __ ] drank all their faces
were big and like they they all like
their mouths were kind of hanging open
well when you looked at the diet at the
time and i remember seeing what they
called the food pyramid yeah in the 70s
and
the food pyramid of the 50s was even
worse it was almost like 80
carbohydrates
and then the rest of it was sewage
fat
with a little bit of [ __ ] protein on
top
so it was mostly bread beer potatoes
yeah just mostly eat that and then like
some lard on top yes
cheese milk
pork
spam and some sardines yeah and some
chicken
some eggs
some vienna the chicken and the eggs are
probably the best things they ever eaten
though i'm sure it probably was i mean
that seems the most nutritious i
remember how many carbs were in the food
pyramid
of the 70s that's what they were
teaching us yeah man that was like
[ __ ] twice the amount of carbs you
really should be eating
cereals and breads
there's lots of it yeah the reason why
they were telling you do this because
agribusiness was making that so they
wanted you to eat what they had yeah
it wasn't really we got lots of this we
got lots of just like that
yeah yeah general mills brought to you
by jim
[Laughter]
cheerios i yeah i kind of feel like a
lot of um this is why i find food
history fascinating because a lot of you
know food
or nutrition rules that you learned like
most of it came from like companies yeah
that were just trying to sell some [ __ ]
right um you know and this is going way
back to the [ __ ] don't forget butter
that's bad for you eat the margarine
no the margarine was much worse for you
than the butter yeah
remember that [ __ ] yep [ __ ] drink
this milk drink all this milk we got
milk drink it up
lactic acid is not that good for you
um
butter and cheese are better for you
than milk
um
yeah it's just
milk provided certain things
that the old diet didn't have you know
that was high in calcium and it had a
certain amount of fat into it
but really that almond milk would be
better for you than
than [ __ ] cow milk today
because you can get calcium and protein
from other other sources that are lower
honestly we don't even buy regular milk
anymore do we we just use that
milk or dried or powdered milk yeah and
then just use it for recipes yeah and
for other [ __ ] we just use almond milk
yeah it's better for you it is and
honestly i don't i don't actually mind
almond milk at all it's okay it's lower
in calorie when i was a kid when i was a
kid i used to really like whole milk but
yeah that's super super fattening well
it's not higher in protein it's lower
and lower in calories and we're getting
protein from other sources that we eat
whey protein is a lot better for it
funny thing is the funny thing is that
nacho cheese is whey protein that's
pretty damn good for you you would think
that that would be really bad for you
yeah no not not really it's pretty high
in protein the calories are pretty low
on that that should taste it tastes
weird to me though it does taste weird
it tastes fake as [ __ ] because it kinda
is i don't like it and then
you can flavor it like chocolate and
call it pudding most of that damn
[ __ ] chocolate pudding out of this
big old cans is just [ __ ] whey
protein
sorry i just had a flashback to that
walking dead episode where carl ate that
whole big thing of like chocolate yeah
it wouldn't be that bad for you it's
got a lot of protein in it
it's not as bad for you honestly some of
the like worst [ __ ] because i know
people pick on [ __ ] like um what am i
thinking of like twinkies yeah i saw one
of those shows about like how it's made
or whatever and they should have made
twinkies i'm like oh my god there's
actually real ingredients in that yeah
i thought
i don't know i don't think they use lard
in a lot of stuff anymore they used it
now they used to use lard in the middle
of oreos yeah when they were good
but they don't really use a lot of lard
anymore yeah there's a misconception
that large is real bad for you and lard
wasn't in small quantities it's not
going to hurt you good it's not going to
hurt you it's a beef product yeah and
it's digestible and it was uh it was a
pretty good source of fat and the taste
was really good
really good it looks delicious sweeten
that lard put it between them damn oreo
cookies and you felt like you ate some
[ __ ] after that
a lot better than [ __ ] corn syrup
a lot better
yeah victor says oreos are vegan
nowadays so yeah they don't they don't
use lard nowadays terrible uh marco says
eggs are probably better than their
reputation too um honestly i think eggs
are one of the best especially
especially if you're like a vegetarian
not vegan obviously if you're a
vegetarian and you want like a good
source of protein that's not super high
calorie like eggs are actually really
nutritious yeah when i wake up in the
morning i know i'm gonna [ __ ] do some
lifting i'll go have an omelette and
that omelette will be made out of at
least six if not eight eggs
because we have buy we buy eggs by the
by the by the case man i love eggs yeah
and [ __ ] it's it's a very high in
protein it's [ __ ] low in calorie um
yeah one hard-boiled egg is only like 70
or 80 calories yes it's like eating meat
you know i mean it's a similar product
might be easy even easier to digest than
meat
but it's very nutritious it'll build a
lot of [ __ ] muscle and they're very
filling too which is nice yeah yeah they
taste good they make good meals i love
omelets and hard-boiled eggs i can sit
around just eat [ __ ] all hard-boiled
eggs all day
i mean i eat two hard-boiled eggs and
i'm full yeah so it's which is good
because then you don't get hungry like
later and that's like like about i like
six to eight of them
i can't eat that many that's a meal to
me i can't eat that many yeah
i can eat an omelette with like three of
them and some veggies and that's enough
hard-boiled eggs for some reason are
like more i guess they're i don't know
if they're more concentrated or
something i ate two hard-boiled eggs and
i'm like all right just i can't eat any
more than that it just seems like it
just fills me up you know what i mean
yeah uh all right so where were we do do
do do do do
where was i okay so we were talking
about how did we get off talking about
food again i don't know it happens
we were talking about fairies we're
talking about the 50s and and pogs
fat ass white girls they're thick girls
yeah
yeah but then how did that happen now
i'm trying to like go talk about the
[ __ ] uh this the uh the safety
we're talking about the safety film yeah
i know that but it's like then it went
yeah and you said all those the men were
all [ __ ] real they almost kind of
looked real chubby
short and stupid well and they all
looked like way older than much older
and it was because the diet it was a
very heart and especially that one woman
that was and that was supposed to be his
wife and i'm like that honestly looks
like his mom yeah
it's very high in carbohydrate diet and
they drank a lot of beer
oh i guess
and um
they didn't live long they just didn't
my granddad was dead by 50 of a heart
attack
and it's because they ate like that they
grew up drinking pork grease
yeah they put in baby bottles all of his
arteries were just like
solid pork rice which that might [ __ ]
some people up what are you talking
about
southern mothers
back in the very early 1900s would put
[ __ ]
bacon drippings
into a baby's bottle
to make them healthy
gotta fatten those kids up fattening
them kids up
so they were born with [ __ ] clogged
arteries
and they just drank pork grease
they'd [ __ ] have a bunch of pork
grease and pork drippings and [ __ ] and
it'd be all they're delicious first of
all they're delicious well yeah because
i like that too sometimes
and they'd be [ __ ] swapping that [ __ ]
up [ __ ] cornbread with [ __ ] greens
and [ __ ] turnip greens and [ __ ] and
eating it off of cornbread
and [ __ ] putting [ __ ] bacon
trippings and [ __ ] crumbled up bacon
and cheese on top of grits
it's delicious but you can't eat like
that 24 7 7 days a week like they did
that would kill you maybe once a week
all right
for like a treat but they weren't even
giving it a rest to clear it out of
their system yeah it's like ooh every
morning i'm going to get up and like
have it i'm going to drink a big bowl of
pork grease on top of like all these
like it has fried potatoes
drink the pork drippings from [ __ ]
four slices of bacon every day easily
easily like i said i'm amazing they
didn't live as long as they did they
didn't eating like that
and honestly if i ate honestly i eat
like that one time and i just want to
throw up it's just like it's too much
you cook a bunch of bacon at once and
then save the grease and put it in a
[ __ ] drippings [ __ ] pot with a lid
on it right next to the
stove so if you needed any oil they just
[ __ ] grab some [ __ ] bacon drips
and put that in a cast iron skillet and
start cooking something with that and
they use bacon drip and so it's just
terrible terrible
terrible for your [ __ ] cardiovascular
system
my dad's had many bypasses heart
bypasses he's basically just a dude
sitting around waiting to die right now
and then because of [ __ ] pork grease
yeah yeah like i said you can get away
with it every now and then yeah but you
can't just grow up from [ __ ] cradle
to grave doing that no way no way
elsa said my nutrition teacher said eggs
are kind of the perfect food yeah i kind
of agree they sort of are protein to
carbohydrate to fat ratio is about
perfect lots and lots of bodybuilders
just [ __ ] eat them down
just love [ __ ] eggs and chicken and
broccoli chicken breast and bro all
chicken on the bone they're going well
chicken breast the [ __ ] that the leg two
the thigh there's not a big difference
yeah because i like nutrition and
traditionally get all this [ __ ]
chicken broccoli eggs
[ __ ] anything made out of whey
protein
whey protein drink
[ __ ] the the weight
based cheese and fake nacho cheese is
pretty good you want a high protein diet
low carbohydrate
you want carbs but you just want them
low
and don't worry about fat just make sure
it's just not
bacon fat that's the worst yeah just
like don't overdo it yeah
which is from beef is nowhere near as
bad
vegetables not as bad but you want to
keep it kind of low
the indians overdo it with curries and
[ __ ] with a lot of [ __ ] vegetable
oils in it you know what i mean that can
catch up with you
cholesterol-wise you have to give his
body time to get rid of that stuff
you can't eat it all the time
david june says my dad still has a bacon
grease container yeah i mean we do too
but we only use it every now and then
every now and then we have like a jar
it's so delicious
anything cooked in bacon grease is
[ __ ] delicious yeah but like i said
we only use everything yeah all right so
where was i we were trying we were
talking about fairies right oh and elsa
also said eggs don't have as much
cholesterol as people think no yeah they
don't they're they're actually like
quite good for you like i said they're
very live off of them yeah they're very
low calorie and they're very high
protein so yeah um very very nutritious
yeah so all right so we're talking about
ireland everybody believed in fairies
like i said you're not talking about
like
friendly tinkerbell fairies we're
talking about very not evil
but just
capricious let's call it that where it's
kind of like if you were nice to them
then they would like do some do you a
solid every now and then but don't piss
them off or they'll really yeah or
they'll like really [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
so what a lot of people would do at the
time just to be on the safe side again
was they would leave like little plates
out for them like on the table be like
hey fairies that one's for you or
whatever and they would just you know
every time somebody said something about
the fairies like somebody will be like
oh bless the fairies or whatever so so
they wouldn't get mad you know so it was
that kind of situation but fairies also
kind of got blamed whenever something
bad happened you know what i mean we had
a bad crap this year [ __ ] fairies you
know
they must be mad at us or whatever
so into this bridgette cleary
at least according to all the accounts
at the time
she was kind of like really into
fairy lore because like i said i guess
this is like the late 19th century so i
guess she did genuinely believe in them
so she was like really interested in
them
so
what she would kind of do at least
according to you know all the accounts
which she would kind of go hang out
at
places where fairies were supposed to
congregate live whatever it was that
fairies do because you know they had
like fairy circles or whatever
fairy forts
uh you know where they would have kind
of and she would go hang out there
so uh in spring of 1895
early march it was
she goes off on an errand um like i said
she kept chickens and she sold eggs so
she went off to deliver a bunch of eggs
to her dad's cousin whose name was jack
dunn
um and this area where she was going to
there was a you know like a fairy fort
which
is kind of like you know from back in
the day where the medieval uh you know
circular fortified settlements were um
and the irish called them fairy forts
and you were supposed to kind of avoid
them because that was sort of like the
area where the fairies lived or it was
sacred to them or whatever and if you
[ __ ] with it they'd get mad at you and
all kind of bad things would ensue but
apparently she was really into it she
would kind of hang out in these areas at
least according to
accounts i don't know how accurate this
stuff is
so she supposedly went to this fort
either before or after she was dropping
off the eggs to the relative
so apparently still early march so it's
still pretty cold out
um so what ended up happening so
bridgette goes out to deliver the eggs
may or may not have stopped at the ferry
for it on the way home
uh but because it was really cold she
gets home
and she seems to have come down with
some sort of ailment uh from the cold
weather or what have you she couldn't
really seem to get warm um she had a
really bad headache you know she was
like shivering and stuff so the next day
she really couldn't get out of bed she
didn't really feel all that well
um so the following day which i believe
was a saturday her dad actually ends up
going to um the next like four like a
four mile walk and he was gonna go get
the doctor because he thought something
was the matter with her
so the doctor i guess that was busy and
was kind of like well i can't come until
wednesday like i said this is saturday
so he's like yeah i can't come out there
and uh so in the interim like her
husband michael had also like walked
over there but like hey doc can you
please come over here and look at her
she doesn't really look all that good
she's really sick and the doctor's like
you know i'm busy i can't do it right
now
so the husband had been over there a
couple of times too but the doctor still
hadn't come
now finally the doctor gets there and
kind of looks at her
and
he tells them apparently
uh nervous excitement
which that's not even what is it what do
you mean that's nothing
um it's kind of made up thing that's
like that's it sounds like woman disease
yeah yeah it's woman disease is what it
is
[Laughter]
and slight bronchitis came up with that
too
uh from being out in the cold but it's
like well it's no big deal but
the doctor said
um
so okay so even though he said it's well
it's not a big deal
um but for whatever reason
her husband right around this time
she'll be sick for a few days and like i
said it probably wasn't anything
really bad she'd been out in the cold
maybe she had
you know the flu or pneumonia or
whatever i don't know what it was but
her husband for whatever reason
became convinced
that
this sick woman who'd been laying in his
cottage for however many days
was not his wife
his argument was
that she was two inches taller than his
actual wife okay
and in his words
she's
too fine to be his wife
yeah i don't know if he means too fine
in the sense of like too refined like
genteel or too fine as in she's way
hotter than my wife i'm not really sure
like which of those two meetings because
that word doesn't necessarily mean the
same thing nowadays and slang that it's
that it meant back then
so i'm not really sure if she's saying
like this this lady is like too hot to
be my wife
or and also this woman's taller
i don't know it was just like this weird
i don't know what convinced him he's
like i this isn't really my wife
because she's not the same
so
uh
his theory was
that i mean it's not funny because this
ended up really really bad but
i don't know what gave him this idea
he thought that when she went to deliver
the eggs and had been hanging out at the
fairy fort
that the fairies had taken her and
replaced her with essentially a
changeling that was what his belief was
so he thought this woman that was
convalescing in his house was not his
wife any longer but a look-alike
okay
and now you can see how
this is not gonna end well
already um
so
so i don't know like the the dude who
was i think it was his uncle
the dude that she had gone to like
deliver eggs to
i think or it was a friend of her
husband or somebody there was somebody
in the town that
was really a believer in this type of
thing
and apparently this guy his name was
jack dunn
and he was kind of like the town
psychic i guess like sorcerers
soothsayer whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it so he was like in this village
he was that guy
and uh so he was supposed to know all
about the fairies and the changelings
and whatnot so it might have been him
that planted this idea in michael's head
that hey that [ __ ] isn't your wife
anymore um i think she's been replaced
so
wait holy crap so i can't even imagine
so after the doctor had come on
wednesday
uh a priest shows up also
now
he didn't seem all that cause he's like
okay she seems like she's sick but she's
gonna get better but just in case
i'm gonna give her the last rights which
might have been a little alarming
there's like well just in case i can't
get back here she's probably not gonna
die but in case she does die i better
have given her the last rights which you
know he's just thinking ahead i guess
uh so yeah so he did give her actually
the last rights even though apparently
he didn't actually think she was gonna
die but you know
um
but the fact that he did that
i guess that kind of like strengthened
her husband's belief that oh well she's
gonna die
um
and that like kind of increased his
stress
even more
and
so he goes and talks to
you know the village
medium or whatever the [ __ ] jack dunn
and he's like what should i do about
this
like she might die is she my wife or not
and jack duns basically says at least
according to accounts jack dunn
basically says
um you better do something right now
because
dude that's not actually your wife and
if you don't do something right now then
your real wife wherever she is um you're
gonna lose her forever it's like this
whole situation
um
so he says it's been eight days
and you should have gone to there was
another dude in town that was like the
fairy doctor
okay that's like what they called him so
i guess he was like the dude that knew
you were the dude that
got consulted on matters of fairy
things
i guess
so you know i get everybody's gotta have
like uh a niche that they feel i suppose
so back then you're the doctor that
dealt with all the uh fairy ailments
you know
so uh so michael
goes to this fella whose name was ganey
and he goes to that guy the next day
and that guy says okay well if she's not
really your wife
you need to
he he gave um michael this kind of like
concoction it was like this you know
spell type of thing and it was all these
herbs
and he's like okay well take this little
bag of herbs and you have to boil it
in essentially the milk like after a cow
has calved and then it you know the
first milk that it produces after that
they call it new milk so you have to
boil it in that because like i said some
witchcrafty [ __ ] this is like you have
to do that
um and then make her drink it
so again making people drink nasty
things
the episode this is basically what this
is
so michael does that
and he makes bridgette drink it and so
michael is there
jack dunn is there the town medium or
whatever and then there's three other
dudes that are like relatives so they're
basically holding this poor woman down
and forcing these herbs and milk
you know concoction this milkshake or
whatever like down her throat right
and then
michael supposedly at least according to
some of the other people that were there
or neighbors or whatever
was yelling at her and this is a quote
take it you witch or i'll kill you damn
all the other dudes start throwing piss
on her what which you know nice
um and so basically like all of these
obviously this
this uh is causing quite a commotion
so all the neighbors and other relatives
and [ __ ] who have heard about this are
all coming over to kind of check out
what the [ __ ] is going on none of them
help her though because apparently they
all
are either scared of michael or they
actually do think that probably she's a
changeling or possessed by fairies or
whatever so they're like okay well this
is for her own good so they're basically
like holding her down throwing pee on
her and making her like drink a bunch of
like disgusting crap
and yelling in her face
uh you know to get out like it's like a
exorcism type situation
so at this point michael says to her
you have to um answer your name three
times so her name her maiden name was
bridgette boland
so he keeps asking her are you bridgette
boland wife of michael cleary in the
name of god and then they take her out
of bed because like i said there's three
or four of them they pick her up out of
the bed and they basically like hold her
like over the fireplace right so she's
like kind of burning right
um because apparently the belief was
that the fairies if you held the person
over fire the fairies would pop out
because they didn't like it it was like
a trial by fire thing so that's what
they were doing so this poor [ __ ]
woman she's like look i just have
pneumonia will you please just [ __ ]
leave me alone it's like why are you
doing this i don't know i can't imagine
what she was [ __ ] thinking
so this goes on for like
at least like 24 hours or more
um and at this point
so all this [ __ ] has happened
uh according to accounts bridget at this
point is quote unquote wild and deranged
i'm like yeah i guess so
i'd be pretty wild and deranged too if
my [ __ ] husband had all these big
dudes coming over throwing holding me
over the fireplace and throwing piss on
me yeah i'd also be pretty deranged
where'd you get the piss
well i guess they produced it they just
pissed it pissing in glasses and throw
it on them yeah i guess i'm i'm assuming
that's what it was weird [ __ ] is that
that's the [ __ ] water sport [ __ ] that
these guys pulled out of the asses
i can't imagine what year was this again
1895. they should have known better by
the 1890s well you would think that but
no
but now
um so
dumbasses
so yeah so she's angry um understandably
um but i guess michael was like okay
well maybe maybe the fairies are gone
now or maybe this is her back or
whatever the [ __ ] i don't i don't know
if he thought that she'd actually been
physically taken away and replaced or if
she thought she was like possessed like
the [ __ ] like reagan and the exorcist
i don't really know what's going on here
so the next day
michael had asked the the priest to come
and then the priest comes much like the
exorcist and says mass
uh in bridget's room and this is
supposedly um
supposed to get rid of like whatever
evil spirits were left kind of hanging
around in the house right
uh so this is the thursday and uh yeah
so she had come she had come back to the
house what on friday or whatever i don't
remember how long it been so that was a
thursday so the next day which is
friday um bridgette had been in bed for
11 days sick at this stage um you know
and getting peed on and whatnot
so 11 days she seems to feel better
so she gets out of bed and she puts her
clothes on you know like she would
and a bunch of their relatives came over
for tea or lunch or whatever
and then while they're all at the table
everything seems cool and like genteel
and everything like that but then uh
a fight breaks out because for okay this
is like so inaccurate innocuous they're
having tea
and scones or whatever the [ __ ] and
bridget very innocently apparently asks
hey can i have some milk probably to put
her tea because that's kind of a thing
they do
and her husband has a [ __ ] flip out
oh my god that's what fairies what
fairies want fresh milk so you must
still be possessed what
she's like [ __ ] yeah all i wanted was
some milk might seriously oh my god
i can't believe like i said it's about
to get like way worse so like don't i
mean oh my god
um
so she at this point she's like look
dude i just wanted some milk because she
didn't say this but i'm pretty sure
probably what she was thinking she's
like look dude i just wanted some milk
why did you [ __ ] calm the [ __ ] down and
then she says to him probably unwisely
all that i'm not blaming the victim i
spare
she says to him hey uh your mom she made
it your mom joke yeah uh your mom used
to hang out with the fairies is that why
you're so [ __ ] obsessed with like me
hangovers because look it's me okay i'm
your wife just chill
uh but yeah she made your mom comment
which probably like i said you and your
mama with them fairies yeah
well she was making the argument is this
why you're so obsessed of me being like
possessed by fairies because like your
mom used to hang out with all the
fairies
your mom's so fat yeah it's like that it
was that kind of thing
uh so of course uh michael did not take
this well uh it's like don't talk about
my mom like that
and so at this point for whatever i'm
not really sure what the cultural
context of this is but he's like okay
[ __ ] now you have to eat
three pieces of bread with jam on them i
don't know if this is because fairies uh
are notorious for not being able to do
that
or i don't really know but he was
insistent
that she had to eat three i don't know
how big the pieces of bread were i don't
know how much jam we're talking about i
don't know if we're talking about like
more than a human could eat i don't
really know
um but he's like yeah so you have to eat
three pieces of bread with jam on them
uh so
and he's like also you have to say what
your name is and you have to say it like
three times because that's apparently
like a ritualistic thing
so she said what her name is two times
which apparently that wasn't good enough
and she could only get two pieces of
bread down because maybe like i said
maybe it was big hunks of bread and
she's like dude
i'm gluten intolerant i don't know so
it's like she couldn't really eat that
much and she when she was gonna say her
name the third time
uh apparently she hesitated a second
which was all michael needed to be like
you are still possessed by the fairies
and he throws her down on the ground
and says if enforces the bread in her
throat right and then says if you won't
take it down you will go that's what he
said according to like everybody if you
don't eat it you're gonna die damn uh
spoiler alert yes that's what happened
yeah man
so he basically like he throws her on
the ground he puts his knee on her chest
and then forces the bread into her mouth
and then he starts ripping her clothes
off because of course he did uh so she's
just there in like her little under
dress or whatever
and then he takes a stick like a burn
stick like out of the fire with like uh
you know embers on it
and starts putting it like up to her
mouth
and then he pulls up her head and like
whacks it against the floor
and then he set her underdress on fire
like with the stick now what's he trying
to accomplish with this he's trying to
get he thinks she's possessed by fairies
this isn't his wife she's a changeling
and he thinks that by
exercising her or destroying her that
he's either gonna get the fairies out or
that he's gonna get his actual wife back
maybe
did he really believe that he seemed to
um but yeah so he set her on fire
um so he had the stick with had the
embers on it from the fireplace and he
puts that like up church it was like her
little underdress like a chemise or
whatever and he sets that on fire and
then he picks up there's like a paraffin
lamp and he picks that up and pours that
lamp oil all the way up close center
[ __ ] yes it's on fire she's alive god
damn he's crazy how much is this
[ __ ] been drinking i don't know
how much has he been drinking i'd have
to drink more than that to set a live
person on fire that's for sure
[Laughter]
i mean
yeah it's terrible he's crazy yeah
obviously yeah he's crazy so yeah so he
pours the paraffin oil like all over
from the lamp like pours it all over her
which obviously makes the flames like go
oh yeah that's like foreign gasoline
outside right
so
she's burning and then okay so it's not
just them two in the house there's other
relatives and [ __ ] if you remember they
were all like having tea like all
genteel and everything and all of a
sudden he just sets his wife on fire as
one does in the middle of a dinner party
i suppose and everybody's just like
everyone's just kind of standing around
like what the [ __ ] yeah well i think
everyone was kind of shocked at first
like i said i think some of them i don't
know if some of them were like just
scared of him and they were scared to do
anything about it or they didn't want to
intervene or they actually did think she
was possessed and they're like yeah you
just you do it
i don't really know but they were all
just kind of like shocked like standing
there like oh my god you just set your
wife on fire and then he looks at them
and he says she's not my wife
uh she's an old deceiver sent in place
of my wife
now at this point i guess the other
relatives were like dude like put her
out please this is like this is going a
little far uh just saying
but so he did actually i don't know if
he actually tried to put out the flames
but they were like yelling and i think a
couple of them did kind of come forward
and try to but by this point like i said
it's like it's that lamp oil and she
just like [ __ ] burned up and there's
like nothing anybody could do
damn um so yeah she just like burned up
like in a couple of minutes
so apparently all the other rulers are
like [ __ ] this and they just like went
in the room and they're just like holy
[ __ ] i can't believe i just [ __ ] saw
that [ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy
so once uh her body is kind of like
burned down
michael wraps her body up in a sheet
shoves it into a bag
and then
leaves the body in there like with the
relatives and he like locks them all in
and then
he basically like he's praying outside
the house for about an hour
and then he comes back in the house with
a knife
and then he says okay one of you [ __ ]
and i think he was uh specifically
talking to bridget's cousin patrick and
he's like one of you [ __ ] gonna help
me bury her or i'm gonna stab you to
death
so you know so no wait hold on
no murder charges
well we'll we'll see how that is we'll
see how that goes
but yeah so
uh yeah so he says to patrick he's like
gonna stab you if you don't help me like
bury her uh i have a hole already dug
so
patrick is like okay just don't stab me
so they were these people i was young
they were i don't know i don't i don't
know actually
their 20s i imagine 20s [ __ ] maybe 30s i
don't know
uh so they dragged the body up to this
kind of bog which is about a quarter
mile away and they bury it in the hole
that he's made
and then michael goes back to the house
and says to everybody that's still there
hey nobody tell the cops essentially so
he did know that he did something bad he
wasn't that crazy
now
the next morning though michael
apparently shows up at the local church
with jack dunn who was like the town
medium or whatever he was the one that
basically said hey
your wife is like not really your wife
anybody who kind of like gave him that
idea or at least that's kind of like
what he said anyway
so uh so jack says yeah you need to like
tell us michael you need to talk to a
priest
so the priest comes in the priest sees
him like uh you know michael's like
crying and like tearing his hair out and
he's like praying in front of the altar
and [ __ ] like that i need to go to
confession i do something really bad
um and the priest is like yeah i'm not
gonna give you the sacrament i don't
think that i don't think this is a good
situation so he goes and talks to jack
dunn
and uh jack dunn actually i don't think
he was actually at the cottage when the
whole burning thing happened even though
it was maybe allegedly his idea
um but he's like yeah but michael told
me yeah i burned my wife to death the
previous night but he didn't think it
was really her
and he says i think that we should go
like dig her up and give her a christian
burial
and then at this point the priest is
like are you guys both high what the
[ __ ] it's like he didn't really believe
it he just thought it was this crazy
story
but he went he's like well i'm gonna go
tell the cops anyway so the priest
actually did go and tell the cops he's
like i don't know if this is like you
might want to go check this out i think
they're lunatics but whatever
so um so the next couple days like the
cops are actually like looking for
bridget because obviously she's missing
um so the friends and relatives of hers
that weren't there they're kind of like
have you seen her nobody had
and uh
apparently during this time michael the
husband was talking about oh he's gonna
leave the country or he's gonna kill
himself or some [ __ ] like that
but he still seemed to believe at least
according to people that like heard him
talking to this time period
that he actually thought even though he
seemed to feel bad about what he did
he actually really did seem to think
that his real wife was going to come
back at some point
um because
they said like for three nights
he went back to that fairy fort fairy
ring thing and he waited there all night
because he thought that the real bridget
was gonna come back on a white horse and
be like oh my god thank you for saving
me i had been taken away by the fairies
like i think he actually thought that
was gonna happen
he was hoping that would happen yeah so
he's like otherwise i am in such deep
[ __ ] yeah i maybe that's what it was i
kind of feel like yeah i think maybe one
thought she was a fairy and then he
burned her up and then he's like it's
like oh [ __ ] i don't think she was
oopsie but he had to stick with that
yeah so maybe yes maybe he's like it
would probably look better if i go and
like wait for her
yeah
so uh so yeah he did that but obviously
obviously she thought she was a fairy
and then i think they're also i think
that she was a changeling
but then uh i think they're leaving part
of the story out [ __ ] was
probably low iq to begin with
and then he would have been deep into
drink when that [ __ ] happened i imagine
this is ireland we're talking about
i mean you drink fish in ireland back in
those days and they wouldn't consider
that as oh he's sober as a [ __ ]
he didn't hardly have any
[Laughter]
it's a drop in the ocean
yeah
not enough to affect you
that's probably how they [ __ ] think
back then you know probably so
i mean the 1800s i mean i'm not picking
on the irish but they're just notorious
well i mean back then they people drank
an alarming amount they had high
tolerance and the same thing was really
going on in the [ __ ] old west and
then you know it was a lot of irish and
german stock you know [ __ ] ended up
in them damn saloons
[ __ ] in the old west shooting each
other up and a lot of things they don't
tell you is that the
fastest guns in the west were [ __ ]
with cocaine you can get it god damn any
dentist or any apothecary well that
would make you the fastest gun yeah and
they were [ __ ] pouring that [ __ ]
inside [ __ ]
wine and drinking it and then they would
drink beer and [ __ ] whiskey all
[ __ ] night
and then then they drink coca-cola to
wake them up and all it had more cocaine
in it those dudes were [ __ ] they were
[ __ ] loaded like i said i can't i
don't know how people lived like longer
than
and a lot of those gun fights you know
it's not like what they'd show you in
these [ __ ] west wild west movies i
mean they had some good ones
most of those [ __ ] gun fights
involved
dudes drunk off their asses
who had smuggled a gun into the [ __ ]
in in into the [ __ ] saloon
because they collected your guns really
you know you've been able to walk into a
[ __ ] saloon
with a gun on your hip most towns
wouldn't allow that they collected your
guns
and the cops took them
and you had to keep them in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] the [ __ ]
at the
sheriff's station you know
and you got it when you left town you
recollected them you signed a men
but they had [ __ ] hold out pieces you
know
little concealable derringers two shot
one shot
you know that those things were even
some of them were muzzle loaders some of
them were percussion caps some of them
you know were [ __ ] you know
percussion cats were muzzle loaders some
of them were [ __ ] metallic case
cartridge depending on what year you're
talking about
so a lot of those gun fights happened
inside the [ __ ] bar with concealed
weapons
shot at very close range or shot at the
back they were shooting people in the
back a lot
sometimes would happen outside the bar
you know and it looked like a gang fight
it would today if you were to see that
[ __ ] if you were to go back in time and
see an old west gunfight it would just
look like crime that's that's all it was
fighting over [ __ ] cards accusing
people of being cheat of cheating
getting mad
that some dude [ __ ]
slept with your girlfriend even though
she's a hooker at the brothel you know
just crazy [ __ ] you know what i mean
she's a hooker at the brothel and you
slept with her and that he thinks that's
his girlfriend so he shot you they did
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] back then
and uh
it wasn't the high noon [ __ ] at all
but uh and some of that happened the
closest thing to the high noon
gunfight in the old west was [ __ ]
shoot out the okay corral between the
client with the clans
and if you read the details of that that
was not
some high noon [ __ ] gun fight that
would have looked more like
gay warfare
well yeah that's what it really was
like real life isn't as cinematic
shot each other in the back mostly
yeah
and they were drunk
a lot of those [ __ ]
yeah they probably even remember what
they did the next day wait did i shoot
some [ __ ] yeah i don't know so
many [ __ ] i can't remember the
closest thing to a [ __ ] movie style
[ __ ]
wild west gunfighter
something like out of the movies would
have been john wesley harden
and he killed he was kind of like our
version of musashi he killed a lot of
dudes
um but they were all considered to be
self-defense
because people were [ __ ] with him
because he had
killed a bunch of dudes to self defense
so you had to [ __ ] kill this dude to
prove that you killed that many dudes in
self defense everybody's going to be
like hey i'm going to go [ __ ] with this
[ __ ] now the caveat to this was
is that
harden could basically shoot anybody and
say it was self-defense they were scared
of him
that he was it's always nice to kind of
get to that plateau isn't it yeah they
were [ __ ] scared
and then that would like feed into that
because like now he's like now i can
just shoot [ __ ] with impunity
and no one's going to do anything
basically so basically he shot one and
now he's lit the legend was he shot a
man for snoring
that's only half true he was drunk up in
the [ __ ] hotel and a dude in the room
next to him was snoring and he was drunk
and that dude was drunk and he shot the
wall to wake the dude up
but it went the bullet went through the
wall and hit the dude
well it got him to stop snoring so
i killed him
but harden was he was acquitted it was
accident i mean he didn't run he fell
asleep and slayed there in the [ __ ]
bed you know what i mean they came and
[ __ ]
he didn't try to flee the scene and he
was like that i hit him i was drunk i
just shot at the wall whoops yeah trying
to wake his he's snoring and everybody's
like yeah i don't want to sleep next to
a snoring person either yeah and he did
do some time
i don't think it was long i think was
six seven eight years something and when
he got out he became during when he was
in when he was locked up in a small jail
really
um they treated him pretty well when he
got out
well well he was in there he studied law
when he got out he was a lawyer
and he made a living as a lawyer and
doing trick shots
he did a bunch of trick shots out in
public you know shooting cards and stuff
shooting coins
some people were saying that some of
those trick shots and those [ __ ]
that those wild west guys oh that's all
legend no some of those dudes were
really good
really good the best one was [ __ ]
wild bill wild bill was [ __ ]
unbeatable if while bill wanted you dead
you were [ __ ] dead
and he was a nice guy though he just had
a wild west show and everything but he
was just the best trick shot probably in
history
he could make a living off doing trick
shots
and people were terrified of him he did
kill some people
they deserved it though
from a wild west standpoint you try to
kill somebody they just [ __ ] killed
you you know tammy says there are nights
i could shoot my husband for snoring
yeah yeah i know that feeling another
feeling so
we're not getting all the story in this
case this [ __ ] was probably
loaded
when this happened i imagine i imagine
most of these people were loaded yeah
pretty much all the time probably
happened at a dinner party where they
were [ __ ] way under the influence
and she was probably loaded
because that's what i'm saying i'm sure
everybody in this situation was probably
loaded so i'm sure it was just not a
good situation right uh gramphthur's
hammer said if you ever watched the ken
burns pbs documentary on prohibition
back in the day people drank all day
every day even kids yeah basically we
were a nation of piss-head drunks yeah
so like i said a lot of cookies yeah a
lot of the crazy-ass behavior
right could maybe be attributed to
everyone just being off their [ __ ]
heads drunk or on and like i said a lot
of drugs were legal yeah
little kids smoked that's another thing
people look kids out there [ __ ]
burning cigarettes but yeah
the [ __ ] funny when you think about
it little kids smoking
it's good for you yeah
it's good for you
but yeah it's a you know like i said
again i was like uh reading drude which
is fiction but he used like a lot of
real [ __ ] that happened
it's about wilkie collins who was an
opium addict
and
something that was going on a lot opium
was legal
um
but you know and laudanum was legal but
it was usually something you'd put like
a couple drops of opium like in your
wine or something to kind of get a buzz
or like as a painkiller whereas wookie
collins was like drinking glasses of the
[ __ ] every day like three big glasses of
stuff um so he was probably like
hallucinating out the ass without eating
like [ __ ] another thing that that
granters who's a friend of mine we grew
up in case you don't know the show he's
a friend of mine who grew up together
he's an ex-law man
um and i wanted to [ __ ] clean
something up
what i told you is true about the old
west but
i don't want to [ __ ] with it i don't
want to [ __ ] or distort american history
the wild west was nowhere near as
violent as people think it was per
capita it was pretty peaceful
especially in those towns it was by
today's standards would have been very
quiet you did have some towns that did
explode into violence but those were
temporary towns mostly around mining
operations and they were only there for
maybe a year or two
and it was young guys dumb as [ __ ] there
weren't any women around
they didn't have much money and they
were trying to make a bunch of money a
lot of alcohol a lot of anything better
to do because
right shoot each other yeah in the top
house in those wild west towns that was
mostly quiet and pretty orderly
all the cool [ __ ] that you see in those
western movies like the clint eastwood
actually was happening out on the plains
between indians and [ __ ] uh settlers
and [ __ ] just white dudes right the
action was on the [ __ ] great plains
that's where a lot of it was going down
and that was kind of like
equivalent to say
the age of empire on the high seas with
piracy it'd be like that pirates
but like i said i kind of feel like
because human history is so long
99.99
of human history is just people just
doing regular [ __ ] and just having like
a quiet normal life and nothing exciting
happening yeah
you only hear about the one percent of
exciting [ __ ] yeah so it seems like a
lot more exciting than it is most people
that went to the so-called wild west
just went out there and have fun and not
much bad happened to them you know they
tried to have for gold or make a living
out in some town somewhere and it was
yes you know they drank and went to
hookers and then like they died of
cirrhosis or whatever the [ __ ] they died
just got got sick and died didn't you
didn't survive some winter for some
reason or another [ __ ] like that i mean
most people just like nowadays uh most
people just died in really mundane ways
they died diseases or
you know in a dumb ass accident or
something like that
um you know like i said most people
don't die in exciting ways my studies of
it is that it was an environment that i
would have loved i would have gone out
there and probably just made friends and
hung out
and done kind of mundane [ __ ] gotten
kind of bored with it done a lot of
[ __ ]
camping out on the range and fishing and
trying to figure out a way to [ __ ]
make possible time on the race
yeah it would have um
it wouldn't it would be anywhere near as
[ __ ] stressful or [ __ ] as
adventurous as most of those movies
would have made it out to be well like i
said a movie is a movie because that's
all the exciting [ __ ] with the boring
[ __ ] yeah all the boring [ __ ] got cut
out most people's lives are like super
super boring yeah but that's why we
watch movies because that's all the
excitement
traveling riding around on a horse deer
hunting and fishing yeah and and making
a fire and sleeping
and honestly everybody like drank and
did so much opium back then they
probably need to remember most of the
[ __ ] that happened to him to be honest
they didn't live long anyway well that's
probably one of the reasons why
yeah if you made it to 50 you were real
lucky that and all the diseases and them
like not washing their hands and
drinking poop water and [ __ ] like that
wasn't that bad in the west no it wasn't
because that was actually cleaner than
because yeah that was clean living yeah
but you know because the comparison
density was so low yeah there wasn't a
lot of other people around to like give
you like infectious diseases and
yeah as long as you you weren't walking
down a street that was like piled high
on either side with like as long as
human waste as long as you weren't
jeremiah johnson trying to make a living
out on the tops of frozen mountains
you know in the winter you're all right
in america america didn't get that cold
if you weren't in the mountains
and i mean as long as you're not in like
[ __ ] minnesota or something yeah
because that [ __ ] gets no we're talking
about in the west in the indian
territory it didn't get that cold in the
winter in that way you could fish all
year around there buffalo and [ __ ] and
deer
they ate pretty well
that didn't last long though you know i
mean trains happened and then cars and
all that [ __ ] but there were dudes that
lived there were incredible generations
of guys that lived like that
yeah yeah
all right so where was i this is almost
done i don't know i swear to god all
right so uh so yeah so this dude
whether or not he really did believe
this or not i don't really know but he
did like kind of hang out at the ferry
for three days thinking that his what
his actual real wife was gonna come back
like you said probably hoping that she
would because otherwise i'm in big
trouble
uh but you know spoiler alert she didn't
so what happened was that the royal
irish constables
they actually put out arrest warrants
not only for uh for his dumbass but also
for a bunch of other people who would
like encourage this
atrocious behavior uh including dennis
gainey who was the fairy doctor dude in
town everybody that had kind of like
just been at the house and not done
anything about it essentially so they
put out like a bunch of arrest warrants
two days later they found bridget's body
she was 26 years old i didn't know that
but yeah i just i just saw that in my
notes she was 26 years old which died
um they had buried her
in this little shallow kind of
hole they'd made in the clay like
underneath all these thorn bushes
um
they said that her spine and her legs
were so were burned so badly
that you could see like a bunch of her
bones like so she was burned like down
to the bone pretty much third degree
yeah and all her clothes were gone uh so
all her clothes have been burned off she
i think she only had like a little
nightgown on but yeah she was naked
she had one stocking on and a gold
earring on and they'd put a sack over
her head for whatever reason
so they arrested all the [ __ ]
uh that were there at the time
and they get brought uh before the
magistrates in uh march of 1895
and uh the whole town had kind of heard
about it at this point and they were
pissed off about this situation i don't
think they believed that she was like a
fair they didn't believe his stupid
story so they were pissed off they all
came like screaming at everybody when
they were brought in so they bring them
all in um and they have a two-day trial
michael cleary is found guilty
of manslaughter
which
yeah i would fit that legally i guess
but well yeah it wasn't uh it wasn't
premeditated no it wasn't apparently and
he it was probably sufficient
provocation to deprive someone of cool
reasoning and calm reflect that kind of
in other words he got so upset thinking
that she was that she wasn't her that he
couldn't think straight and did it so
yeah
so that yeah so i guess like it sounds
dumb but like yeah when you think about
it yeah logically that that means to
kill his wife he meant to kill
this change the changeling and he was so
upset he couldn't think right yeah yeah
so
so that was the correct right uh that
was the correct i think that's good i
suppose
he should have done some time though but
you know he does feel sorry for the [ __ ]
i don't think he did well yeah
but uh like you said it might have been
a situation where
she was sick for all this time oh yeah
probably well she was sick for a long
time i'm not really sure what the
illness was it seems like she was out
she was running errands like she was
delivering eggs like she did she had a
business you know like selling eggs so
she was out doing that it was really
cold and then she got back
and she was sick and she was in bed for
11 days so she might have had like
pneumonia or some [ __ ] like that but i
guess
for whatever reason her husband became
convinced that because of this illness
she's possessed that she must be like
possessed or this isn't her yeah um it's
weird because i kind of feel like later
on some people have speculated i don't
know if this is the case then there's no
way of knowing unless you invent a time
machine but some later people have
speculated maybe
michael was suffering from what they
call what do they call it a capgras
syndrome cap cross syndrome where you
think that everybody around you is a an
imposter
like looks exactly like oh hey you're my
family but not my family you've all been
replaced by yeah exact duplicates i've
heard of that before um yeah it's very
rare but it does happen it's a weird
like psychological disorder so they
think maybe he had that yeah and then
was able to kind of like convince
because it does seem like
i don't know because i do kind of feel
like there is some evidence that
his wife
bridgette had said something to one of
her relatives or friends like three
months prior to this incident
that
um
that he thought that she was a fairy and
he and that he was gonna burn her or she
said something like that so this might
not have been the first time that this
happened yeah so maybe he had some kind
of like psychological disorder where he
would periodically go into these weird
like fugue states where he thought that
she wasn't her you talk about
schizophrenia
yeah maybe he had some kind of problem
like that maybe i mean
i don't think she was doing because some
people speculate well maybe it was her
maybe she was like cheating on himself
but i'm like but still that doesn't
justify
you like setting her on fire alive jesus
christ
just divorce her for [ __ ] sake it's
like don't i don't think that's what it
is i don't think so either i think there
was like some other [ __ ] on a mental
problem yeah and he thought she was a
[ __ ] change
schizophrenia maybe or just
superstition and alcohol mixed together
whatever it was he was [ __ ] tripping
yeah
but i mean so he did get imprisoned yeah
um you know and a bunch of the other
people like jack dunn the the town
medium or whatever the [ __ ] he was uh he
actually got imprisoned also um so did
uh
remember oh i don't know it might say
like later on in my notes but yeah jack
boland or patrick boland who was the
other guy who helped conceal the body
yeah uh he got some prison time also and
also so
four of british uh bridget's cousins who
were there like holding her down like
when he was trying to like do they got
some prison time too so you know like
that's good verdicts all around gotta
say they if they actually did kind of
get
um the judge said well i don't think
it's like murder murder because they
actually did seem to think that it
wasn't really her
but they still need to be punished
because they still did some bad [ __ ]
right yeah but they did actually yeah
but he's like they did actually seem to
believe that they were doing something
you know not you know
uh stop other people from doing that
same [ __ ] yeah make samples out of them
so michael did do a lot of prison time
so he went in in 1895
he didn't get out until 1910. okay so he
was in there yeah so he was in there for
how long is that 15 years 15 years he
was in for 15 years
uh which you know that's that's pretty
good so he gets outlined right yeah
he gets out and he got on a ship for
montreal yeah and um
i don't think anybody heard of him after
that so he must have gone like
disappeared living up in the cabin
somewhere yeah jack done the town medium
he got three years
um he
yeah well i mean he didn't do it he
wasn't there he inspired all this [ __ ]
yeah like michael like later said i
wouldn't have done it but jack done like
convinced me that she wasn't really my
wife and so maybe i wouldn't have done
it i don't know if i believe that or
entirely maybe he's just trying to like
assuage
responsibility
obviously obviously but he did yeah so
jack dunn did get three years uh he got
out he came back to the same town um and
just went back to work like you do
um you know so
but as i mentioned earlier
when bridget was sick like during the 11
days she was bedridden when all of this
terrible [ __ ] was going on like before
she got [ __ ] burned alive or whatever
um her aunt came over to visit her
and she apparently said
michael's making this is a quote
apparently according to her aunt
michael's making a fairy of me now
he thought to burn me about three months
ago so this is apparently not the first
time this has happened at least
according to her so maybe the husband
was like abusive or maybe he
this was a delusion that he that's what
it sounds like to me yeah i kind of feel
like this is maybe a delusion that he
had had proof but
how scary is that though
i mean and i was like schizophrenia well
because tammy was saying earlier she's
like can you imagine
what she was thinking it's like this is
her husband this is somebody she's
with every day it's like somebody that's
supposed to love you and everything like
that and like all of a sudden they get
this weird idea in their head that
you're not you anymore or you're like
possessed by fairies oh i'm not gonna
burn you to death it's like what holy
[ __ ]
you could be some rare thing like you're
talking about but i'm gonna say it's
more more something real common like
schizophrenia oh
you know i mean they get
certain kind of paranoid
paranoid delusion
you know i mean it's got to be something
like that she thinks that that's not her
and like i said later on people said oh
maybe she was like [ __ ] around on him
and stuff like that i'm like i don't
care if she was [ __ ] around that
doesn't like that is not even jermaine
to the situation
what that doesn't justify like what he
did to her is what they mean no they
don't mean they don't mean to justify it
they're just trying to say that maybe
that's what he was thinking so he was
coming i don't think so though that he
was coming up with some crazy ass story
to like do it but still it seemed like
i don't think so either i think like he
really actually did seem to think at
least briefly yeah that that wasn't her
he was having some kind of paranoid
delusion it was yeah and he thought she
was a fairy
that's sort of like so scary though
because that's something that you can't
predict that's something that you can't
it'd be just like some dude thinking
that she's a witch yeah you know what i
mean holy crap can you imagine yeah well
if you're wrong place wrong time that
could cost you your life yep and it did
i think that dude's a witch i think
she's a witch i think my wife's a witch
and [ __ ] yeah they'll [ __ ] press
your ass
and he just and the skit the scary thing
to me and like i said i saw there was a
show and they did like a reenactment of
this but can you imagine
being
you know that being her and just like
you know she's sick for whatever like i
said it sounded like pneumonia or
something like that so she's in bed for
like 11 days she doesn't feel all that
good then all of a sudden like her
husband and all these other dudes like
of relatives they're like coming and
holding her down like make her drink all
this stuff and like you know are you bur
very simple very similar to the
possession thing and yeah and it's like
that and then like all of a sudden i'm
pulling her out and then just send like
setting her on fire
oh my god i can't basically it's an
exorcism yeah that's what they were
doing but you know i think what you're
dealing with you do dude has some kind
of paranoid delusion he's worried he's
afraid she's [ __ ] possessed holy crap
and he's not mentally all that stable
and he finally she gets sick and it
finally gets into he's like yeah she's
the she's possessed
and you know you're dealing with a bunch
of drunks and some of them have [ __ ]
weird you know what i mean uh
superstitions and their cultures are
based in superstition and they
jump right to action okay
we're going to get the fairy out of here
we're going to take care of this and you
know and if you're that if you're that
woman
when you think about it there's nothing
really you're going to be able to do or
say
because if you try to reason with them
they're going to go oh look the fairy's
trying to talk its way out of it i mean
that's what's so scary about being able
to do anything yeah well see that's what
always scared me about like all the
witch panic type of stuff because it
seemed like
if somebody anywhere just like pointed a
finger at you you were [ __ ] there was
nothing you could say
that would convince them otherwise
that's what you're doing once they had
decided you're dealing with with a witch
panic yeah in one house way out of date
i mean this is late in the late 1800s
these [ __ ] this is almost the 20th
century yeah they're supposed to know
better which makes me think of uh
not bad education
alcohol
low iq [ __ ]
dude's got some kind of damn paranoid
delusion
and he thinks she's a [ __ ] witch
basically
and he's just they're drunk and he
starts the cycle of [ __ ] witch [ __ ]
and
and they [ __ ] kill her
you know i mean and uh and like you said
once it got to a certain point i don't
think there's anything that she could
have said
that would have and honestly there's
nothing she could have done either
because there was it wasn't just him it
was like there was
you know three or four other dudes in
the house yeah
that apparently bought into the same
delusion so they were there to like hold
her down so she couldn't like escape
yeah
god can you imagine how scary that would
be i'm thinking alcohol's involved god
damn that would be so [ __ ] scary
alcohol and just stupidity
and then there's just like this group
synergy
you know yeah that's what i mean all you
need is like one dude that's like really
convinced of something yeah and a bunch
of dudes that are just kind of like
whatever and you can like talk him into
it yeah which that's not her that's like
i'm telling you right now it's my wife i
would know wouldn't i yeah you can see
in him like saying it's just like him
yeah
that's what happened horrifying that's
[ __ ] horrifying a long time ago
though i know but it's like still
i don't know i i always kind of like put
myself in the place of
that person it's like i just can't
imagine like what that must have been
like you used to have stupid [ __ ] like
this happening well i know that like
people are over in thailand and
they're stupid here there's stupid
people everywhere stupid people are
eternal
every now and then they try to exercise
something about kid and it kills it you
know what
yeah it happens here yeah hey we're
gonna like put all these cushions around
the kid because we're pretending that
they're being reborn and it's like a
womb and stuff and then they suffocate
yeah i remember like reading something
about that and that was like here that
was like in the [ __ ] midwest
somewhere they had this with that one
little cult out in the desert they were
some kind of uh african muslim cult or
something remember that and they had
they crucified their own kid
remember that [ __ ]
that was a weird [ __ ] they had all the
damn
they had all the damn trucks in a circle
they showed camera of uh [ __ ] um
helicopter shots of it
they thought it
it
it was some weird mixture of
christianity and islam and and stuff
they were going to bring back the mahdi
if they sacrificed this boy and it was
that it was the leader's son
and they thought that the sun was a
reincarnation of jesus and so he had to
die in order for the mahdi to come back
don't you remember that
vaguely i kind of that was some weird
[ __ ] too you know what i mean and he he
did that to his own son
out in the middle of the desert
that's some weird [ __ ] just a pro tip um
all that shit's not real so
your kid is just your kid
please do not sacrifice them they're not
possessed by demons i promise
please don't do any of that stuff i mean
it's just like none of that shit's real
please please stop it i don't know it's
it it just bums me out
it bums me out it bums my little atheist
ass out yeah that people will still do
[ __ ] like that will kill their own
[ __ ] children yeah
because they believe that so strongly
it's like look it's not real it's like a
[ __ ] fairy tale i think the first
super chat of the night from zachary all
right god damn it thank you i'm maybe
i'm behind oh thank you a story that
always used to upset me was the little
autistic boy who was killed in an
exorcism because the priest convinced
his parents he was possessed yes see
that kind of [ __ ]
that makes me just so so sad
so sad like i said it's just
if you believe something so strongly
that you would kill your own poor
innocent child over it
i mean
ugh can i can't think of anything more
tragic than that yeah if you guys can
remember that case i thought of god damn
it drop that in the comment section i'd
like to [ __ ] find out some more about
that i remember when that happened and
then there was like a rumor
that they let them all go that they
didn't charge them
for crucifying the boy i don't know if
that's true i find that hard yeah i find
it hard to believe too but there was
like a rumor that they that they let the
guy go
i don't think so though but the thing
about it is that in some way it depends
on what religion you are obviously
but
in some cases they will give you a
religious exception but i do not think
that should be i don't think that should
be taken into consideration i think that
you should be given a psychological
assessment because obviously you're not
mentally right yeah if you're doing that
[ __ ] but i don't think
i don't get this whole oh well we
genuinely thought that they were
possessed by a demon so we killed them
because we thought yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that
you're a terrible parent you should have
never had children
all of that's [ __ ] please do not
please do not kill your children doing
that oh my god that makes all right so
this uh this store this one is over this
case is over
yeah
all right
and uh i guess we'll go ahead and call
it a night huh
you think yeah it's getting late you
want it it's not it's no it's not even
eight o'clock what you want to sit
around talk some more what's on my
what's with my voice i i don't know
have you noticed that you're sitting
wrong if you know it sounds the same
no i'm just saying well i know because
it's my voice
for the last
week and a half two weeks yeah
like i've been doing videos if you guys
have uh watching my videos like all the
ones that i put up the last week
sometimes i'll say words and like the
word just like drops out because my
throat sounds like it's like [ __ ] i
don't know what the deal is man i don't
know you might have a little bit of cool
i don't know if it's cold or allergies i
don't know what it is i don't feel like
i have a cold but i've only been
streaming though uh three hours three
hours okay
all right grandpa's hammer says come on
keep going
[Laughter]
we go for a little bit i guess i'm
getting kind of hungry this is like the
pre-halloween special though going a
little bit longer yeah i just like i'm
you know these two cases were kind of
short and like i said they're kind of a
bummer but at least they happened a long
time ago it's a three-hour show though
yeah that's not sure it's not short yeah
well
the five hours that we normally put well
that's what i'm saying we normally do
and probably that's the thing we we
normally do like four or five hours so
it's like when it's three hours like
what it's only three hours
like [ __ ]
you know what i mean uh
mike cohe says you shouldn't toy around
with what you don't understand honestly
though it's like i kind of feel like
i don't know i just
the older i get a lesson the less i
believe in that stuff and it's just kind
of like
these people that would actually
kill their children because they
actually believe that they're possessed
by demons and stuff like that i don't
really i don't think they should be
given given any
dispensation also like look you're a
dumbass that's your fault yeah the fact
that you believe that stuff it's like we
don't have to like give you a [ __ ]
pass because of that you killed a child
yeah i don't think it's dumb though i
think what it is it's insanity
yeah well yeah i mean that has to be
determined if you really have some kind
of mental illness then that's a
different issue i i think it's almost
always mental illness
i mean i don't know
i don't know it's a i know it's like a
[ __ ]
it's like a gray area i get that
but religions can attract the mentally
ill they mentally well they do in a
large yeah yeah it doesn't mean you're
crazy if you believe in religions it's
just that crazy people fall right into
religious religions they can hon they
they'll [ __ ]
swallow that [ __ ] hook line and sink or
sometimes and then they'll go out and
sacrifice somebody but you know there's
a but a lot of [ __ ] that's wacky people
will believe in
you know crazy people will believe in
[ __ ] that's wacky like a moth to a flame
you know what i mean
yeah and see that's where the problem
lies that's where i'm saying that's
where there's a gray area because i'm
not saying that everybody that believes
in religions is crazy because obviously
that's not the case because there's
billions of people that believe in
religions i don't but i'm not gonna like
[ __ ] on people that do
but
there's also the case where
people that are already mentally ill
are very attracted to
these types and and very like extreme
religious positions and honestly like a
lot of people that have
uh certain types of disorders like
epilepsy or something like that like a
lot of the
um you know in schizophrenia a lot of
the kind of like hallucinatory like uh
episodes that they have are religious in
nature
so
there is kind of like a correlation it's
not causation but there is a correlation
between
very very high religious belief and very
very high
mental illness there are like i said
it's not the same thing
they're correlated but
one doesn't cause the other but they are
correlated
so
i don't know that's always been kind of
like interesting to me so but like i
said that's why there's a whole gray
area because
a lot of the mentally ill though they
get into religion just they interpret
religion they the way they want to
interpret it they'll mix three or four
different religions together and make up
their own stories about it it's yeah
it's always self-serving they kind of
well yeah and i kind of feel like that's
true of everybody but it's all like i
said it's all like kind of a matter of
degree isn't it because you kind of get
to a point where
you're kind of like um
fitting stuff into a pre-existing you
want the religion to like fit into some
[ __ ] that you've already figured out
yeah
and if you
have some kind of like mental illness
and you have like some really weird kind
of [ __ ] that you figured out
then you're going to like kind of
pretzel that religion into
into that [ __ ] that you've already
figured out i yawned if pookie would
find that [ __ ] unacceptable i can't
believe pookie's been sleeping over the
whole time
she's just like what you guys can't see
her but she's right she's right there
she's in the chair next to me she's in
the chair yeah we put that chair there
with her little toys in it that elsa's
that yeah
um yeah elsa is still here oh she loves
the crinkly yeah she liked it
[Music]
you like that crinkly dracula
she's looking at like
yeah when i open that when that i opened
that earlier it's like it's a dracula
and it's like a little black cat and
they're crinkly and i'm sure they have
like a cat nip in them so i took them
both out of the bag because she was like
open the bag open the bag so i took them
both out and i put them on either side
of her face and i was like we love you
pookie and she was so into it she was
just kind of like oh yeah graham says i
watched solo last night on
show times about a stripper from detroit
it goes to tampa for a weekend and crazy
[ __ ] happens based on true story and a24
studios made it plus
i don't know that show
yeah we're gonna have to watch that
what's it called again zola yeah
but we're gonna have to see what
happened in tampa all kind of crazy [ __ ]
happens in tampa
crazy shit's happening in tampa right
now tonight i mean crazy [ __ ] always
happened to taylor i used to live in
tampa so i know yeah and we've been to
tampa many times yeah every time we go
to tampa crazy [ __ ] happens
tampa's kind of like in new orleans so
[ __ ] of uh at least ybor city is yeah
i mean ybor city is technically part of
tampa yeah that's the new orleans of
florida that's like the old town yeah
part of tampa that's where all the
pirates used to hang out yeah although i
heard that the keys are [ __ ] [ __ ]
really fun too
down there
one of these days we'll have to go i
don't think you know what i've lived in
florida my most of my life i was born
here
i don't i've never been to the keys
yeah never been in the keys
but if you go to the key he's going to
have to go fishing really that's all you
do down there yeah but that's boring
yeah be born to you i mean well i went
fishing a lot when i was a kid yeah my
dad was into fishing
probably
that's true yeah one of these days our
friend will was kind of like oh man you
guys need to cover the keys with us like
do a vacation
yeah
i mean the bars down there there are um
it's kind of known for that yeah it is a
very new orleans vibe but not but more
florida-e and more cuban-y yeah than new
orleans a lot of sand and [ __ ]
but it's like a drink it's also kind of
um you know marta garritaville yeah like
jimmy buffetty jimmy buffetty which
[Laughter]
i'm not super jazzed about that i mean i
think i've told this story before but i
first moved to tampa
i mean you you live in florida you're
aware of jimmy buffett okay everybody
knows who jimmy buffett is in florida
it's kind of a thing
i moved to tampa
and i started working at this print shop
and the dude that owned the print shop
was seriously the world's biggest jimmy
buffett fan like of all time
it fine okay i'm not judging but
he had this one jimmy buffett cd i don't
know which one it was
and he used to play it over
and over and over and over yeah and i
worked at this place for a month and i
said literally i think i'm gonna kill
myself if i have to hear this [ __ ] cd
one more [ __ ] time and he had this
other kid that worked there that was
like 18 or something and this 18 year
old kid
and i imagine this is probably why he
hired him
this 18 year old kid was also like the
second biggest jimmy buffett fan
in the universe
so so i kind of they were just like ooh
they were simpatico yeah so that's why
he hired him like he could do some
printing [ __ ] too but you know so this
18 year old kid so while i worked there
i worked there a month and that i
couldn't take it anywhere
but while i worked there
the owner who was probably like in his
40s or 50s i don't remember how old he
was and the 18 year old kid went to see
jimmy buffett live because i guess he
played there at some stage
and after that happened
it was just like if it was bad before it
was like 10 times worth like the jimmy
buffettude was just
it just went off the charts after that
point it's just like and they were so
excited and they would like play the cd
over and over and they'd be like
remember when he did this and that and
they were like singing along and i'm
just like oh my god please that's funny
please kill me oh my god i just i
couldn't take it anymore she's talking
about they made a movie called beach bum
oh my god the movie beach bum expresses
exactly what the [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i i was very familiar that was that
had a lot of buffet in it a lot of
[ __ ] drunk worthlessness in it snoop
dogg was in it because that [ __ ] lives
down there
yeah it was it was very much like that
yeah and i was kind of like i just i'm
not from the same universe as you people
i don't really know what's going on
um elsa said there's an 18 year old
jimmy buffett fan i was also surprised
yeah um
i didn't know that existed
apparently it does uh there at least
there's at least one
so
and if like looking at him i can't
really remember i kind of have a hazy
memory of him
but
he didn't really look like like if he
was walking down the street you wouldn't
be like hey jimmy buffett family
parrothead or whatever they call them
now the parrothead i think they call him
i was like you wouldn't think that
um
so i was very surprised also but man the
two of them were just kind of like oh
man
and that cd just that it was kind of
like when i had a house in daytona and
like our next door neighbor i can't
remember what his name is
our next-door neighbor was like the
world's biggest leonard skynyrd fan oh
yeah which is another thing
this is why i'm crazy the biker bar is
[ __ ] leonard skinner [ __ ] this crazy
so the dude next door to me
was the world's biggest leonard skinner
fan when i owned a house in daytona
and also
he liked to work out in his yard at you
know starting at 6 30 a.m now i worked
the night shift
um you know so i were i didn't get home
until like 3 3 30 in the morning so i
like to sleep to like nine or ten at
least
this [ __ ] gets up at 6 30 7 o'clock in
the morning blaring
that same leonard skinner greatest hit
cd or whatever the [ __ ] it was
singing along at the top of his lungs
let's do that smell
that smell well yeah can't you smell
that smell hell yeah
can you imagine putting out a single
nowadays called that smell yeah yeah
i'm like what were they thinking
thinking about weed i mean yeah i get
that but like the you know [ __ ] man the
drugs back then it's like people would
not be thinking about weed
i don't think about weed that's when you
say that smell they knew how to sell i
think about wait are you talking about
like after you've like you know crushed
the bathroom and it's like you [ __ ]
destroyed my toilet it's that smell
that's everybody's gonna think that
sorry
i know weed smells bad i get that but
it's like you know but yeah so
it's kind of the same thing
that dude
so i'd be woken up at between 6 30 and 7
every morning so i only have like three
hours of sleep so like i said this is
why i'm still cranky this many years
later because for many years i was
denied
sleep
because my stupid [ __ ] neighbor was
blaring leonard skinner at seven o'clock
in the morning mowing his lawn or doing
his edging or whatever and screeching
along with like sweet home alabama or
whatever and
[ __ ] man
i even tried like blaring punk rock out
the window at like certain times like i
was like i was like i would put the i
would put the like stereo at the window
like blast the dead kennedys or
something but like it didn't work it
didn't work i tried but he didn't really
seem to get the message i don't think he
really he wasn't a bad guy
i just think he was oblivious
no he thought that she was cool he
didn't yeah he didn't think that anyone
would be bothered which like i said in
some ways
i don't know is oblivious worse than
malicious because you it's like they
don't even it doesn't even occur to them
that like it might be bothering somebody
so i was like [ __ ] i work at night
stop waking me up okay if there's any
questions or anything we can we can uh
answer
from you guys
before we go ahead and sign off if not
we're gonna go ahead and sign off camp
guy said i saw kevin smith tell a story
about sitting on a toilet and breaking
it off the wall
you know kevin smith the guy that made
clerks and oh okay that guy yeah yeah
he's lost a lot of weight since though
yeah i don't think he could break a
toilet nowadays
you know yeah
all right so we're gonna go ahead and
shut it down people
looks like uh super chats are drying up
looks like people are starting to leave
and zach just pointed out and i had
forgotten about this so thank you for
reminding me uh i kid you not a24 i
think released a movie last year called
her smell yeah i remember that and it's
like i haven't seen it yet because i'm
like i'm not going to watch anything
called that i'm sure it's a good movie
but because it's a 24 all their shit's
good but
i'm not watching a movie called that
sorry yeah i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i don't i don't even like that word you
know how some people don't like the word
moist
i don't like the word smell
okay you know what i'm saying not really
don't call anything smell it's a smell
yeah i don't want to smell that weed
no all no if you say that all
i think of like is like fart smell
that's all i think of i don't think a
weed
like i said yeah weed smells bad but
that's not like the first thing that my
brain goes to
and i don't think it's the first thing
that most people's brain goes to
yeah all right
all right we're going
you ready to go are you hungry i'm ready
to go i'm hungry what are you gonna make
maybe we'll go buy something it's only
eight o'clock
oh wait is it yeah
wait you can't drive yeah okay
you sure yeah
i can drive i could ride my bike
i could go to the damn biker bar right
now if i wanted to
uh uh
yeah okay
[Laughter]
i don't believe nobody oh i can
i won't but i can't
all right yeah
again i don't believe you
i'm i actually i'm not i'm not drunk
sexist don't die y'all no no well try
not to i mean that's kind of like
that that's my daily affirmation don't
die today yeah that's kind of what i
only had two
that's true i'm on my third one yeah i
had two but yours are bigger than mine
yeah but i got a good tolerance
i said why yeah i don't really don't you
don't think your toddler's as good as
mine
i'm just saying
i don't know if that's the case i don't
know if that's the case tammy says uber
and mike says take it uber we're in a
[ __ ] country you don't have [ __ ]
uber here
i kind of doubt that uber would come out
we had a hard time getting internet out
here uber
yeah we told you guys about that story
we still don't have honestly it's good i
think it like um
it kind of hiccuped a couple times when
i was still on the starting soon thing
but it hasn't uh [ __ ] up since then
yeah so hooray
but you know
every this is like the fourth [ __ ]
internet service that we've tried and it
actually sort of works most of the time
yeah it works good enough
this is the [ __ ] one that came with
the for free
well it's not free it comes with the
[ __ ] it comes with the hope the hoa
which is 90 a month but you're already
paying that anyway right so
i still have to like cut off that
satellite yeah cut that [ __ ] off
because honestly that's it's too [ __ ]
slow it's not working it doesn't work
when we stream it's like it's not even
good
it didn't deliver its promise so it has
to go
yeah i mean i'm keeping the [ __ ] from my
phone just like i said for a backup
anyway but and you could kill that
without [ __ ] any uh
with without a uh breaking any kind of
contract or anything
yeah all right
so uh
hopefully everybody's had a good time
yeah we will see you guys and we're
gonna do ooh friday night yeah friday
night sidetracks and friday night is
also the friday night before halloween
because halloween's on sunday yeah so we
should probably do like a halloween
special man that means i gotta put up
the projectors and [ __ ] i should go
ahead and do that well i thought you
were gonna do that a long time ago
look at this is what it is okay look
let's go
i gotta replace so many lights out there
it's kind of too late now we don't even
have any
halloween candy oh my god i gotta kill
the power to those lights out there so
halloween's like [ __ ] sneaking up on
me okay i might like i'll try to do like
a costume friday night but it might be
something like super simple like i might
just do like wednesday adams or
something because i already have a [ __ ]
for that because like i said i don't
have like a lot of time or money
to come up yeah and i don't you know
what i don't think i've ever worn that
dress on the show before i've worn it
out a lot of times but i haven't worn it
on the show i can just do i can just
braid my hair it'll be fine
it'll only take five years it'll be cool
i'll try to come up with something
better for like sunday because sunday's
like actual halloween yeah her wednesday
outfit makes her look [ __ ] thick man
booty and legs and [ __ ] big boobs
he's like getting all [ __ ] dreamy
about it yeah
i do like that dress it's very
comfortable you bought me that yeah all
right so we will be back friday night
for a side tracks halloween special
we'll talk about whatever the [ __ ] maybe
we'll have some candy it'll be fun
um everybody says don't drive drunk yeah
we're not going anywhere we got food
here
well let's call dominoes that's what i'm
saying
it's only a mile away don't tell me what
to do people
i've got so much [ __ ] experience and
i'm not drunk or like i said we got
dominoes and that's like right up the
street they could deliver to be honest
you gotta tip those [ __ ] yeah so
they're right there go ahead they're
right there all right so we'll be back
on friday night
thank everybody for dropping by
you guys are awesome we'll see you guys
on friday
bye